the first thing that tips the foundation
off to
scp-087's presence were the reports of
numerous unexplained disappearances on
campus there were plenty of rumors about
what might be behind them but field
agents suspected that the true source of
the vanishing would be something Beyond
civilian imagination all anyone knew for
sure was that everyone who had gone
missing was last seen in the certain
Administrative Building on the
University grounds and that the
disappearances only seemed to happen
when the elevator was out the campus was
soon flooded with Foundation agents
creating a barrier around the
administrative building and the presumed
habitat of
scp-087 nobody else could get in and
hopefully whatever was inside couldn't
get out one of the foundation's lead
scientists was flown in to consult on
the investigation what could have been
behind those students disappearing the
doctor's preliminary interviews with
University staff who worked in the
building yielded some interesting
details strange noises like banging and
even a faint shrill crime would be heard
from a door that led to a no longer used
stairway in hallway 3B staff in the
building had no reason to overtake these
stairs especially considering how many
of them reported a strange sense of
unease when just standing outside the
dorm the only reason someone might take
those stairs is due to elevator
malfunctions
in that instant the doctor had put it
all together the staff they interviewed
had their memory wiped with amnestics
special chemicals used by the foundation
with the power to delete human Memories
the foundation only used them for staff
or civilians who had confirmed contact
with an SCP and the doctor knew that
they had a live one on their hands
staircase there was something terribly
wrong with that staircase and it was the
SCP foundation's job to find out what
before it made anybody else disappear
this is the story of
scp-087 otherwise known as the endless
staircase and the three Doom Journeys
down into its murky depths the doctor
was more than eager to begin Research
into the staircase and its frightening
anomalous properties after all don't
claw your way up to being one of the
foundation's key researchers without
being brave and perhaps just a little
bit deranged as with standard once a
perimeter was secured around the
staircase the good doctor requested a
selection of d-class personnel for
testing for those not in the know
d-class is the foundation's polite way
of saying cannon fodder the doctor was
sent three d-class prisoners for use in
his investigation of scp-087 the first
d-8432 was according to official
documentation on the incident a 43 year
old male of average build and appearance
and unremarkable psychological
background this man once worked for the
foundation in a more official capacity
but he was given the often deadly
demotion to d-class due to a dangerous
mistake handling
scp-682 that led to the deaths of
several other agents now it looked like
it would be his term the doctor
explained his mission to him explore the
staircase gather data help us find out
exactly what we're dealing with here if
you come back alive there may even be a
promotion in it for you and with that
promise d-8432 was given his Loadout a
75 watt flood lamp with battery power
capable of lasting 24 hours an audio
headset and a handheld camcorder fitted
with a transmission strain d-8432 was
then pushed through the door in hallway
3B and out
staircase according to Declassified
Foundation files describing the
staircase
scp-087 is an unlit platform staircase
stairs descend on a 38 degree angle for
13 steps before reaching a semi-circular
platform of approximately three meters
in diameter descent Direction rotates
180 degrees at each platform the design
of scp-087 limits subjects to a visual
range of approximately 1.5 flights but
in d-8432's mine unlit really didn't
seem like the right word he would have
chosen all-consuming Darkness despite
carrying a powerful 75 watt lamp d-8432
was only capable of partially lighting
the platform he was standing on and the
illumination only stretched down nine of
the 13 steps to the next platform
when d-8432 observed how little help his
lamp was giving him he was instructed to
shine it out of the doorway into hallway
3B when he did so the light seemed to
shine far further than it ever could in
scp-087 already the beginning of the
anomalous activity was obvious
everywhere else darkness is just the
absence of life in scp-087 darkness eats
light it was like a tangible black mass
that only a certain amount of light
could survive while the rest just
wouldn't show d-8432 swallowed hard over
a lump in his throne the door to hallway
3B was closed behind him and he was
ordered to descend surviving to see that
promotion was feeling unlikely but it's
not like he had a choice
tried to escape scp-087 before he was
permitted he'd be shot by SCP Foundation
field agents on the spot so he followed
the high-ranking doctor's orders and
began to descend the steps to the next
platform nothing about the physical
makeup of the staircase itself seemed
abnormal the base and walls were a very
plain dull concrete with a metal
handrail the only thing that seemed
unique about it so far was the strange
life-bending properties at once
reach the second platform down and he
heard it a soft echoing cry a child's
cry who was shrieks of Panic or maybe
even pain echoing Up From Below he was
asked why he had stopped and he
explained the crying sound he'd been
hearing it sounded like it was coming
from far down the stairs maybe 200
meters below him he could just make up
the words please health and down here
coming from the darkness but the team
outside the stairwell couldn't hear
anything so they asked him to descend
further another platform down and they
could hear it too the unmistakable cries
of a terrified child please help and
d-8432 was ordered to keep going and
only stop if he noticed changes to the
visual environment or in the sounds he
was hearing d-8432 knowing his life was
on the line had to keep going and
descended another 20 flights of stairs
before stopping to remark that the
sounds of the child hadn't gotten any
closer they still sounded just as far
away as when he'd first heard them he
was told his observations were noted and
pressured to continue within half an
hour d-8432 had descended a full 50
floors with no sign of a bottom in sight
somehow the volume of the child's crying
had remained consistent throughout as if
it was moving away from d-8432 at the
same rate he was descending at this
point d-8432 reported that he was
feeling uneasy the doctor said that this
was understandable given the
circumstances he'd been watching what
little there was to see over a live
video feed the entire time and something
about the truly bottomless nature of the
staircase ever elusive crime was
undeniably but things were about to
really take a turn for the worst as
d-8432 stepped forward towards the next
set of stairs he froze there was
something on the platform below him
barely illuminated by the light of his
75 month old was a face vaguely human in
size and shape but was a few terrifying
differences it had grayish skin and no
mouth nostrils or pupils and yet d8432
could feel that this
eye contact with it he couldn't move
trapped in the famous piercing gaze in
an instant the face jerked forwards
suddenly only about a foot away from
d-432's face eyes staring into its own
da432 screamed and ran scaling all 50
flights in an astonishing 18 minutes
before charging out into hallway 3B
there he collapsed from the exhaustion
and fear of what he just seen upon
reviewing the footage the strange face
was designated
scp-087-1 fascinating it was time for a
second experiment the doctor just had to
know more the second test subject was
d-9035 a 28 year old male with a history
of aggravated assaults against women he
was given the same Loadout as his
predecessors except this time with an
even more powerful 100 watt bulb he was
also given 100 small LED lights that had
adhesive backs and a battery life of
approximately three weeks with which
they intended to permanently illuminate
has cp087 however despite the extra
wattage of his bulb he still couldn't
illuminate beyond the ninth step
scp-087 wouldn't allow it having no
ideas of the horrors that lurked below
him he descended on the doctor's orders
and began fixing the LEDs to the walls
of each platform he passed the LED
always illuminated The Landing but the
light couldn't pass the first step on
either side the flights of stairs
themselves would remain in Perpetual
Darkness after the second flight
d-9035 noticed the same crying d-8432
had heard and became uneasy just like
before as d-9035 descended the volume of
the crime didn't seem to increase as if
for every step he descended the source
of the crime descended one too keeping
them at a constant 200 meters apart
still He was ordered to continue his
descent and the placing of LEDs even as
his paranoia grew when he reached the
51st floor he observed damage to the
wall and steps sections appear to have
been smashed to Rubble by an extreme
force as he descended past the broken
step he only felt his fear and anxiety
and paranoia grow the doctor made note
of the fact that scp-087 seemed to cause
instances of anxiety and Terror in its
occupants even before they encountered
scp-087-1 as d-9035 reached platform 89
a full 350 meters under the initial
platform he stopped dead in his tracks
and saw something staring up at him from
the platform below that same terrible
gray face with those dead white eyes he
was encouraged to stay calm and try to
get better footage of the face but a
charge for him and d-9035 ran for his
life he ascended the staircase at a
staggering Pace even passing out from
exhaustion and remaining motionless for
14 minutes halfway when d-9035 finally
gathered the strength to get up and
scrambled back to hallway 3B and fell
into a state of Catatonia he remains
unresponsive to all external stimuli to
this day just staring off into the
distance with a haunted expression
almost
hallway the doctor wanted to conduct one
more test before he ordered scp-087 shut
off from the world forever and it was
the most terrifying of all the final
subject was d-9884 a 23 year old woman
with a history of depression and use of
excessive force the doctor had hoped
that d-9884 would travel the deepest yet
and so he gave her the additional
supplies of a backpack containing 3.75
liters of water 15 nutrient bars and one
thermal blanket as far as the foundation
was concerned she was in this for the
Long Haul but none of them had any idea
quite how right they were
when d-9884 entered scp-087 all the
lights from the previous Expedition had
disappeared still she was ordered to go
deeper she heard the crying of the
mysterious child if it was even a child
at all and again she was ordered to go
deeper at the 496th Landing even as Dean
9884 seemed to slip into a state of
mortal Terror once again she was ordered
to go even deeper every moment he was
hoping to get a better look at the face
of
scp-087-1 and when Dean 9884 finally
broke and fled back upstairs he did the
face appeared but this time it was mere
inches behind her staring directly into
the camera with its blank eyes startling
even this veteran of the supernatural
the face appearing caused Dean 9884 to
panic inflate but instead of going back
up the stairs to safety she went deeper
down the staircase in an attempt to
escape it deeper and deeper and deeper
until her video feed cut out d-9884 was
never seen again in the aftermath of the
tests the SCP was classified as Euclid
it may have been dangerous but at least
it was easy to contain the door to
hallway 3B was replaced with one made
out of reinforced steel with an electro
release locked mechanism it has been
disguise to resemble a janitorial closet
consistent with the rest of the building
the lock won't release unless a
classified number of electrical volts
are applied while the key is turned
counterclockwise and after a few inches
of foam insulation were applied to the
inner side of the door staff at the
building never again reported hearing
strange noises as for the fates of those
lost within the endless turning flights
and platforms of
scp-087 we may never know but one can
only assume it isn't Pleasant
ah here we go again it's time to return
to the acid-filled containment chamber
of
scp-682 more commonly known as the hard
to destroy reptile we've spoken about
him and the ways the SCP Foundation has
attempted to destroy him in a previous
video but as we said back then we really
only scratched the surface of the huge
number of insane ways the foundation has
tried to wipe this cranky lizard off the
face of the Earth today we're filling in
some of the cracks and taking a look at
the secret test logs detailing the
foundation's unsuccessful quest to
finally destroy
scp-682 some of these may surprise you
and if you're a real SCP expert you may
just recognize some familiar faces we
meet along the way esteemed Foundation
researcher Dr Alto cleff famed for a
somewhat unconventional personality
entered the test chamber to see if he
could intimidate the Beast to death this
resulted in a long staring contest
between Dr clef and 682 towards the end
of the competition Dr cleff began to
lose his nerve he tried to leave the
room only to find that the door was
locked causing him to swear loudly Dr
cleff Who always tries to find the most
direct solution to his problems blew up
the door with plastic explosives and ran
off the result test failed next came
scp-662 a silver handbell that summons
The supernaturally Helpful Butler Mr
Deeds when Mr Deeds was summoned
Foundation researchers asked him if he
could kill
scp-682 Deeds politely explained that he
wouldn't be capable of killing 682 it's
just too strong when he asked if he
could at least incapacitate 682 he
replied that the best way to do this
would be to poison himself and allow 682
to eat his body but this he reminded
would only be a temporary problem for
the lizard another test failed the
foundation brought in
scp-689 a terrifying soapstone statue of
a sitting skeleton that can kill you if
you see it and then stop paying
attention to it 682 first observed the
statue and then the foundation turned
off the lights when they turned them
back on
scp-682 appeared to be dead in a puddle
of gray and black liquid d-class
Personnel were sent in to confirm that
682 was actually dead but it instead got
up and killed them researchers theorized
that 682's definition of life is not
quite the same as ours rendering 689's
death-related Powers ineffective test
failed yet again
scp-807 was next up to bat this is an
anomalous salmon-colored ceramic dinner
plate with the words Last Chance Diner
printed on the edges in white any food
placed on it becomes Irresistible by any
definition but when the food is consumed
it causes immediate Cardiac Arrest due
to the sudden clogging of arteries with
fat researchers made a meal known as the
682 special 10 kilograms of rotten Mead
and sharpened bone splinters 10 liters
of rancid mayonnaise one liter of
potassium Cyanide and one kilogram of
morphine hydrochloride combined into a
solid mass and transmuted by 807 when
682 to consume this disgusting meal it
appeared to collapse however when
d-class Personnel were sent in again to
see whether 682 was truly out for the
count multiple holes opened up in its
body these holes fired out high pressure
Jets of blood killing the nearby
d-classes and destroying the containment
cell 682 was fine afterwards another
test failed to kill 682 it seemed that
the foundation really needed to have God
on their side so they tried to recruit
scp-343 also known as God to help them
destroy the Beast however when he
entered the containment chamber he
somehow couldn't even see the beast when
researchers asked him whether he could
kill 682 God replied he's not one of
mine deal with him yourself test fell
before it even began next the foundation
recruited
scp-524 a small white rabbit that can
eat literally anything including its
self without being harmed the rabbit was
released into scp-682's chamber at which
point it approached 682 and began to eat
one of its legs 682 roared in pain and
scuttled up the wall Out Of 524's Reach
where it remained for a number of hours
at this point scp-524 seemed to become
bored and began eating its way out of
containment through a nearby wall test
failed maybe the Luck of the Irish was
what the foundation needed to finally
put this monster to rest they recruited
scp-1933 a fat man dressed as Santa
Claus whose bodily fluids consist
entirely of the alcoholic beverage known
as Irish cream if enough of this man's
self-produced Irish cream is fed to
something they'll find that all of their
bodily fluids have become Irish cream
too killing them the foundation fed
large quantities of this Irish cream to
scp-682 and it actually had an effect
causing 682 to appear intoxicated which
was a promising sign however it soon
vomited out a massive quantity of
scp-1933 bodily fluids turning the walls
of its cell into Irish cream and
allowing it to escape and wreak havoc
test failed big time the foundation
recruited the help of
scp-2337 an intelligent Corn Creek known
as Dr spenko with a voice so loud it can
quite literally talk its victims to
death if it speaks to them for an
extended period of time it was sent into
scp-682's chamber to attempt to destroy
the beast but 682 just told it to leave
and the talkative bird obliged by
blowing away one of the chamber walls
with a yell allowing scp-682 to breach
containment again terrible job Dr spenko
test failed the foundation researchers
were starting to get a little frustrated
with their lack of progress which you
can no doubt sympathize with and they
even pitched the possibility of sending
scp-682 into an alternate Dimension
where perhaps it would enter into a
stalemate against its alternate self but
this pitch was shot down by the o5
Council on the grounds that it was way
way way way too risky back to the
drawing board by which we mean they
literally transformed 682's skin into a
kind of drawing board
scp-2521 is an anomaly that manifests
anytime information about it is recorded
and immediately grabs the source of the
information wrapping it in its tendrils
and taking it away with it the
foundation sought to take advantage of
this by using a laser cutter to cut this
anomalous information into
scp-682's side however this didn't have
the results they were hoping for
scp-2521 did turn up to take the
information but it only took the skin on
which the information was carved 682
survived and quickly grew back its skin
test failed again researchers suggested
tracking down scp-169 an obscenely
massive underwater creature known as the
Leviathan and feeding 682 to the Beast
however this idea was also immediately
shot down by the o5 council if 682 did
what it did best which was surviving
attacks and adding them to its own
Arsenal then it might grow to the size
of
scp-169 which would likely trigger an XK
Class end of the world scenario it
simply was not worth the risk test
failed before it even started the
foundation released two specimens of
scp-939 into 682's test chamber these
voice imitating Amnesia inducing
monsters have caused huge damage to
human targets so it was hoped that they
may be able to do something to 682 but
this hope turned out to be misplaced
both specimens seemed extremely
distressed by 682's presence and refused
to engage at all 682 did not share the
same apprehension about attacking it
charged in and brutally killed both
before devouring their corpses test
failed in a very well-documented case
the adorable scp-999 was introduced into
682's test chamber The unassailable Good
Vibes provided by 999 as well as an
intense tickle fight did actually lead
to the temporary incapacitation of
scp-682 however the otherwise wholesome
incident ended in tragedy when 682
adapted to the Good Vibes and was able
to release a kind of violent laughter
wave this incapacitated much of the
staff and allowed 682 to breach
containment and go on another Killing
Spree before being recontained test once
again failed the next test involved
scp-294 an anomalous coffee machine that
can produce any liquid typed into its
keypad Foundation researchers requested
scp-682 killer from the machine and were
astounded by the results during tests on
the liquid with SC
scp-682 tissue samples the liquid was
surprisingly effective and caused the
682 tissue to Decay and crumble tests on
the living creature were similarly
promising the acid in 682's tank was
temporarily lowered and one liter of
scp-682 killer was poured onto the
reptile's head causing that portion of
its flesh to immediately Decay when the
acid was returned the same portion that
had the liquid poured on it dissolved
instantly test well not quite successful
but promising and requiring further
Research Foundation scientists believe
that if they could one day get a large
enough quantity of this liquid they
might have a viable option but until
then the tests march on for another
experiment they introduced
scp-055 into the containment chamber of
scp-682
scp-055 also known as the self-keeping
secret is a mysterious anomaly that can
only be described by what it isn't for
example we know that scp-055 is not
round but that was pretty much it now
however we know something else about
scp-055 that it can't kill
scp-682 test failed but at least we know
twice as much about scp-055 as we did
before next came
scp-082 better known as Fernand the
cannibal fernan was first presented a
piece of Flesh from 682 but rather than
eating it he inspected it and began to
express joy that his friends still live
when introduced into 682's testing
chamber Ferdinand attempted to subdue
the lizard and use it as his Steed 682
expressed an intense hatred for both
Ferdinand and the idea of being ridden
like a pony and the two of them engaged
in combat mobile task forces were
eventually brought in to subdue both
subjects in a debrief interview both
hinted that they shared history prior to
containment but 682 was reluctant to
talk about it further test entertaining
but still a failure researchers were
becoming extremely frustrated with
scp-682's unwillingness to die so they
called in an SCP who responded to reason
much better
scp-049 the plague doctor this Sinister
surgeon can kill with a touch and the
foundation hoped that his abilities
would extend to 682 however the result
was a dud the plague doctor did touch
682 but it experienced no adverse
effects and eventually swiped at the
doctor upon leaving 049 reported feeling
emotionally disturbed by his encounter
with
scp-682 yep you guessed it test failed
if he gives you any indication of just
how desperate the researchers were at
this point Dr Graham pondered whether
introducing 682 to a human with just as
pessimistic and misanthropic feelings as
itself would somehow pacify it they sent
in a particularly nasty d-class and the
two spoke fascinatingly 682 didn't
attempt to harm this d-class they just
shared their profane and Bleak
sentiments about the human race with one
another however some of 682's opinions
were a little too spicy for this d-class
after listening to the reptile speak for
20 minutes the d-class fell into a
catatonic state from the sheer
depression of it all he died not long
after one researcher suggested perhaps
the worst idea of all letting scp-682
out into the wild not even really to
terminate it just to see what it does
the scientists figured there would be
some Merit in analyzing the creature's
Behavior this idea was submitted
anonymously of course it seems even the
most sadistic of researchers know better
than to put their name on an idea like
that as you can probably guess this
request was shot down by the o5 council
the note attached to the request by one
of its members summed it up best I'll
tell you what it will do it'll go out
for a nice stroll murder a few innocent
people go fishing slaughter a few more
innocent people start up a tech company
eat a few more innocent people go on a
vacation to Florida dismember a few more
innocent people I swear when I find out
who wrote this you can personally enter
682's containment chamber to analyze him
yourself over 50 men and women clad in
red robes kneel before an Unholy altar
they chant and mutter indecipherable
words words of Cruelty and Madness of
obsession and sacrilege not long ago
these were regular people computer
technicians teachers plumbers
construction workers accountants this
was before they fell under the ungodly
influence of a new ruler the center of
this makeshift place of worship was once
a normal school gymnasium but it's now
the home of a huge statue a humanoid
being wreathed in tentacles its head is
more like a squid or cuttlefish than
anything resembling an actual human face
while he's known to the cultists as the
tentacled god the Beast they worship is
known to the SCP Foundation as
scp-2662 and he sits in the belly of one
of their expansive containment
facilities locked away from the world
but not for long if his devoted
followers have anything to say about it
this is their God all-powerful and
unchanging and when it comes to
springing him from containment no tactic
is too vile or underhanded to get the
job done their mortal leader and high
priest a man in a purple robe calling
himself brother Marsh walks among their
crouched forms he whispers instructions
for the great day of Liberation that's
soon to come providing everyone plays
their part it's a plan months in the
making and one that if it goes off
without a hitch could free their
monstrous God into the world they would
strike at the very heart of their enemy
the SCP Foundation when they least
expect it and nothing shall stand in
their way how could they lose when they
have a God on their side but why did all
these normal people become violent
zealots for a squid-faced deity it all
began with a dream to those who
experience these dreams they felt more
like prophecies premonitions of the
Glorious Horrors to come a red sky
billions dead and billions more enslaved
a dark silhouette on the horizon their
tentacled God hold holding Dominion
overall at first it just seemed like a
strange nightmare the ones who
experienced it woke up shaken in afraid
hoping to shake the images from their
mind but they couldn't every night the
nightmare would return they'd see the
images the Red Sky the dead and Enslaved
the tentacled God and after a while it
would come to them even when they
weren't asleep eventually happening
whenever they closed their eyes little
by little this scene stopped looking so
hideous and started to look glorious
they felt his presence in their minds
slowly pushing them towards their
inevitable future they started to
realize that they wanted him to rule
over the universe and to experience the
honor of serving him many of them
abandoned their homes and families
leaving their friends and loved ones
left to worry that they'd Gone Insane In
Their Eyes they were safer than they'd
ever been they finally had purpose they
were working in service of something far
greater than themselves the influence of
the tentacled god drew them closer to
one another
they would meet in secret exchanging
information from the prophecies their
rulers sent to them in their dreams they
worshiped together building altars and
Idols to congregate around they
performed dark blood rituals involving
human and animal sacrifice it was when
brother Marsh the anointed one arrived
to guide them towards their true mission
that things kicked into high gear just
three months prior brother Marsh had
been an office drone working in data
entry for a large insurance company
before the tentacled god invaded His
Thoughts with a simple message free me
and the new world I create shall be your
playground since then he devoted himself
completely to the cause quitting his job
and maxing out his credit cards to help
fund his new life's purpose infiltrating
the SCP Foundation and releasing his
inhuman ruler from its imprisonment that
was the single goal he United the
cultist under freedom for the tentacled
God and at long last they had all the
pieces in place to strike they'd finally
gathered the necessary Intel to subvert
the will of the most powerful secret
organization on Earth even the strongest
institution is made of people and people
are weak unlike the almighty tentacled
God people could be broken the people in
question were Kelly Thompson Sydney
Levitt Jordan brosh Dr Juan Gutierrez
and Jillian Larson Dr Juan Gutierrez was
a researcher with level 3 clearance on
the site where the tentacled God was
being contained Sydney Levitt and Jordan
brosh were both security officers
charged with verifying Personnel
clearance on site Kelly Thompson was a
member of site Administration with
research authorization powers and
Jillian Larson was a research assistant
who often collaborated with Dr Gutierrez
these five were the key to getting
access to
scp-2662 and bringing their plan
to fruition normally Personnel dossiers
on people working for the foundation
were highly confidential but the
devotees of the tentacled God had their
ways they had a number of computer
experts in their ranks more than capable
of hacking in and pulling some basic
information off of foundation servers
without being detected for the other
information they needed they turned to
some good old-fashioned torture which is
often the most effective method when you
need some quick results of course while
the Colts grip on sanity may have been a
little tenuous they weren't stupid while
Gathering their Intel they also made
sure to find out what exactly they were
up against
scp-2662 was being held in a humanoid
containment cell and guarded by on-site
Task Force Town nine better known as the
belligerent bodyguards these aren't lazy
donut chomping Mall Cops these are a
heavily trained heavily armed fighting
force though the cultists had one thing
that these Foundation soldiers didn't
the element of surprise for everything
to go off perfectly brother Marsh's
plans would have to be executed within a
single day and they were already on the
clock Tau 9 had been charged with
tracking down any new
scp-2662 Cults and dismantling them and
brother Marsh knew that it was only a
matter of time before the foundation
tracked them down and did the same to
them if they wanted any chance of
freeing the tentacled God then they'd
need to strike quickly and with
overwhelming Force the
scp-2662 worshipers were able to secure
the addresses of the five key Foundation
personnel and station members outside
each of them including one who could
realistically imitate each they waited
for night to fall and broke into each of
their homes as they slept what followed
was a sequence of Ruthless and efficient
murders done in the cause of freeing
their God Dr Gutierrez was shot in the
head while he slept Sydney Levitt and
Jordan brosh were both stabbed to death
before either even realized what was
happening Thompson who'd gotten up to
use the bathroom went down in the hail
of machine gun fire Jillian Larson had
seen that mask Figures were breaking
into her home and attempted to flee but
was caught and beaten to death by
cultists in her hallway it was a strange
irony that people whose day jobs
entailed working with some of the most
dangerous and nightmarish anomalies
imaginable were murdered in their homes
by nothing more than regular humans
so far brother Marsha's plan had gone
perfectly with all five key personnel
murdered within a two-minute period next
the selected doppelgangers stole clothes
from their victims closets and were
handed the correct Forge documentation
the next morning each replacement began
their Journeys to the site where the
tentacled God was being contained while
the rest of the cult armed themselves in
preparation for their own part in the
plan
nobody at the foundation seemed to
notice anything amiss when the five
arrived on site when you work for the
SCP Foundation more mental energy is
devoted to following the rules that keep
you alive then two memorizing the faces
of all your co-workers and each one slip
neatly into position disappearing into
the familiarity of office life but
infiltrating the site was one thing
getting past the belligerent bodyguards
and into the cell of the tentacled God
would be another thing entirely that's
where the rest of the cult would come
into play heavily armed with whatever
Firearms they could get their hands on
the rest of the devotees of the
tentacled god brother Marsh included
would attack the containment site head
on in the ensuing chaos the five
cultists who had already infiltrated the
site could take advantage of the
distraction and break into the
containment chamber
was perfect they launched their attack
from the outside and from within when
brother Marsh declared that the time was
right the assault began a legion of gun
wielding cultists seemed to Spring out
of nowhere and started shooting up the
warehouse that was a front for the
containment site the site quickly
mobilized guards and task force members
to take on the sudden threat and just as
brother Marsh had anticipated the site
director called on the majority of town
9 to help repel the violent cultists
from their perimeter Town 9 obeyed
leaving three task force members behind
a guard
scp-2662's containment chamber they
expected to be guarding the cell from
rampaging religious zealots seeking an
audience with their God what they didn't
expect was a group of five Foundation
employees walking right up to them and
opening fire killing two Tau 9 members
and taking the third as hostage while
the war was being waged outside the
infiltrators had found the tentacle
God's containment cell in the low-risk
humanoid War their hostage insisted that
you using him wouldn't give them any
leverage the rest of his team would
neutralize the whole group him included
if that's what it took to stop them the
infiltrators explained that using him as
leverage was never their intention he
wasn't a hostage at all he was a
sacrifice
the cultists of the tentacled god
detonated explosives creating a hole in
the wall and finally giving them access
to their deity they climbed through and
gazed upon him in awe there stood
scp-2662 twice as tall as a regular man
with 10 huge tentacles emerging from its
back in their months of envisioning this
creature they pictured it sitting on a
throne made of thousands of human bones
ready to dictate its commands to the
obedient liberators what they certainly
didn't expect was to see the tentacled
god hunched over a computer screen still
God's work in mysterious ways so they
stuck to the plan and began chanting
they pulled out a sacrificial dagger and
began sacrificing their captured tau9
member it was at this point that
scp-2662 turned and saw what they were
doing with a look of pure horror he rose
up from his computer his headphones
getting caught as he did so he told them
to go away that he didn't want here and
that them murdering people in this
bedroom like this was inconsiderate and
disgusting the cultists became even more
confused why wasn't their God accepting
their offerings what were they doing
wrong they tried more chanting and
painting Arcane symbols on the floor and
blood but this just seemed to make the
creature angrier he told them in a tone
more fitting for a teenage boy than a
lovecraftian God to just leave him alone
so he could play his video games this
was seriously not cool the cultists were
baffled they told the tentacled god that
they were there to free him he replied
that he didn't need saving
that crazy stalkers like them were why
he turned himself into the foundation in
the first place before the cultist
infiltrators could get another word in
the remaining members of town 9 stormed
into the containment cell and gunned
them down with surgical Precision the
war outside was already over brother
Marsh and the rest of the cultists were
all killed in the firefight Town 9
didn't look the least bit surprised upon
entering 2662's cell this was a common
occurrence Unfortunately they had to
deal with an attempted cult Invasion
every few months because
scp-2662's main anomalous ability is
inspiring violent Cults who relentlessly
Tracked Down and Worship it with Arcane
and bloodthirsty rituals the problem is
2662 doesn't do this consciously and
definitely doesn't like the results
that's why he's under the voluntary care
of the SCP Foundation who keeps him
amused with video games and reading
material while fending off the deranged
Cults who try to invade and abduct him
following the termination of the
devotees of the tentacled God just one
of many Cults who'd broken into 2662's
containment cell the remaining Town nine
members apologized to the tentacled
creature for the disturbance allowing
him to return to his gaming they assured
him that it'd probably be at least a few
more months before something like this
happened again
scp-2662's cell was repaired and the
foundation returned to its task of
seeking out would-be cult emancipators
because for the SCP Foundation it's not
always about the anomaly that's being
kept in containment but what's being
kept down it goes without saying that
the SCP Foundation archives are filled
with some terrifying monsters even the
deadliest creatures can in theory be
defeated or at least soundly avoided
after all they're just flesh and blood
or in some cases metal or concrete but
what if reality as you know it one day
just broke or worse you were transported
to a reality so frightening and alien to
our own that death seemed like the only
Escape but you couldn't even give
yourself that this brings us to today's
topic the terrifying alternate reality
of
scp-3001 the foundation is no stranger
to freaky alternate Dimensions but what
was experienced by joint lead researcher
Dr Robert Scranton at site 120 is a
truly unique nightmare co-managed by his
wife Dr Anna Lang site 120 is a facility
largely designated for Research into
scps with dangerous reality warping
capabilities in order to mitigate future
containment breaches reality warpers are
among some of the more perplexing and
dangerous scps from the pocket Dimension
creating scp-106 to the SCP creating Dr
wondertainment and everything in between
Scranton and Lang's goal to further
study such entities was an admirable one
if a little over ambitious and on
January 2nd 2000 during the testing of a
new technology created by the
foundation's leading power couple
disaster finally struck
Scranton and Lang had already been the
brains behind one of the foundation's
most valuable tools in the fight against
reality bending scps the Scranton
reality anchors their follow-up the Lang
Scranton stabilizer or LSS likely would
have been an even more advanced variant
of their earlier invention and should
have been a huge success for the team
but things didn't turn out that way Dr
Scranton and several other researchers
were gathered in reality lab a
performing routine tests on the LSS
prototypes while other technicians ran
Diagnostics tests Scranton stood at the
control panel the blinking red light
above the console confirming that
everything was going according to plan
but as anyone who's Fallen victim to one
of the foundation's many anomalies will
tell you just because you've done
everything correctly doesn't mean you're
safe Scranton began operating the
machine not knowing that something was
rumbling up towards him from below
without warning a sudden unexpected
burst of seismic activity rocked the
entire base researchers grabbed on to
whatever was closest as the world shook
around them in his Panic Dr Scranton
clung to the LSS control panel as the
seismic blast fried the circuits and
kicked it into overdrive
there was a blast of magnificent
blinding light and when the rumbling
stopped Not only was the doctor gone he
had been erased from reality as we know
it the earthquake had caused a deadly
malfunction in the machine meant to
stabilize reality and instead tore a
rift in it dragging the unfortunate
doctor and the control panel into
Oblivion
his wife Dr Lang and the many
researchers who idolized him were
devastated by his unexpected demise at
the hand of what should have been his
crowning achievement the one silver
lining was that this reality ripping
event had almost definitely eliminated
the doctor quickly and painlessly as far
as the foundation and his loved ones
were concerned Scranton's death had been
immediate and complete a luxury afforded
to few Foundation employees who die
anomalous deaths but sadly that isn't
how Dr Scranton's story or the story of
scp-3001 ends no this is where it all
begins how do we know all this in the
hellish new place where Scranton had
been transported the control panel from
the LSS that he'd been clinging to for
dear life had been transported with him
and continued to record audio data from
this anomalous location not that Dr
Scranton realized it not at first anyway
as far as he knew he'd suddenly been
transported into a pitch black location
no sights no sounds no sound
true nothingness at first the doctor was
confused one second he was testing out
his new technology and the next he was
quite literally nowhere in spite of his
current situation the doctor was still
an intelligent and rational man he took
a moment to compose himself hoping that
in time his eyes would adjust to the new
Darkness around him but that moment
never came
the darkness remained perfectly absolute
much like the darkness in another
reality-defying SCP the deadly endless
staircase known as scp-087 the dark
seemed thick almost like you could touch
it the doctor not wanting to give
himself to Despair and die in this
impossible place and with no other
options seemingly available began
walking either he'd find his way out or
the foundation would find him no need to
panic it may have altered the doctor's
temperament if he knew that the
foundation already assumed he was dead
and that no search party was going to
come looking for him
still logic dictates that if a person
walks for long enough they're bound to
find something the problem Scranton was
about to face was that scp-3001 doesn't
run by any kind of conventional logic
he walked and walked and walked but he
didn't seem to get any nearer to or
farther from anything but how could he
even know after all in total darkness
there aren't any landmarks to assist in
navigation the doctor walked and paced
and screamed for days on end but he made
no progress he was alone in an empty
world he had no choice though so he kept
walking and walking and walking for 11
days during that time he felt his hunger
and thirst grow he was in terrible pain
from a mix of starvation and dehydration
but the release of death didn't seem to
come for him he was going to have to
learn the rules of this new place the
hard way and it grimly dawned on Dr
Scranton dying in this place might not
even be the worst possible outcome he
paced and repeated facts to himself
hoping to ground himself in the moment
and avoid the Panic that could so easily
set in name Robert Scranton age 39
birthday September 9 18 1961 favorite
color blue favorite song Living on a
Prayer wife
Anna little by little the words seem to
turn to nonsense in his mouth as the
terror grew just as he felt like he was
about to lose his mind he noticed
something a small Oasis in the endless
darkness of
scp-3001 the glowing red light on the
LSS control panel where had it come from
and how was it still recording the
doctor had no idea but he was grateful
for any kind of familiarity in this
strange Darkness around him perhaps the
LSS could be the key to saving him or at
least figuring out what on Earth was
going on here whatever the case there
was no denying that having the panel
here was better than nothing at least
when it was found if it was ever found
then people would know what had happened
to him as the days passed and he
continued to mysteriously survive Dr
Scranton deduced that one didn't need
food or water to survive continually in
scp-3001 the location had an anomalous
effect on its inhabitants
as the days passed and turned to weeks
of wandering in the darkness Dr Scranton
further deduced that he was no longer in
his home Dimension this was an entirely
separate pocket Dimension much like the
one possessed by scp-106 but featureless
a perfect self-contained void
now dimly illuminated by the red light
of the panel Dr Scranton explored
further into the void around him he
traveled for months on end the pain of
his deficiencies growing by the day but
found he was getting nowhere
All Things Considered he wasn't even
sure he was moving or whether reality
and darkness were swirling around him
like a thick liquid rather than walking
on a single flat surface he was moving
in all directions across a
three-dimensional plane the space-time
Continuum appeared to be entirely broken
here where movement is more defined by
the conscious intention to move than any
real geographical repositioning Dr
Scranton knew that this place broke
every single one of cajel's laws of
reality parameters and from his years
working with a plethora of reality
warpers in sight 120 he had a theory for
why this pocket Dimension was so strange
it had an extraordinarily weak Hume
field before we get back to Dr
Scranton's semi-living nightmare we need
a quick primer on Hume Theory and why
having a weak Hume field is such a
problem a Hume is a unit of measurement
for the strength and amount of reality
in a given location or being in an area
with an incredibly low Hume field
relative to our world such as scp-3001
Universe breaches and anomalous
incidents rise significantly at the time
is being trapped there
scp-3001 had the lowest number of Humes
in any recorded environment making it a
phenomenally anomalous Zone it was for
this reason that starvation and
dehydration never took hold of him
despite causing him great pain and the
worst by far was Yet to Come Dr Scranton
wasn't trapped in this dimension for
weeks or even months he was trapped in
the darkness for years and it took a
nightmarish toll on his body and mind
the small flashing red light on his LSS
control panel became his only friend and
as the years Drew on he would hold
entire conversations with his only
source of Illumination he knew that his
days were numbered if he didn't escape
the dimension within around three years
the Hume field would defuse further and
he would be left in a truly horrific
state but based on how little Headway
he'd made in the time he'd been there he
didn't feel optimistic he kept speaking
into the recorder if only to break the
silence and prevent him from going
completely insane but even that would
only hold it off for so long alone and
talking to himself endlessly in the
darkness Dr Scranton could feel his mind
slipping as the confines of the pocket
Dimension constricted and his body began
to change the low Hume field slowly
diffused his physical matter destroying
the physical Integrity of his body but
never being merciful enough to actually
let him die in this haunting audio logs
the doctor described his hands as
diffusing and thinning out like spider
webs over time there was less and less
of him and what was left wasn't entirely
human as Scranton's Hume level lowered
to equalize with that of scp-3001 the
lines between his body and the LSS
control console began to blur in a
Twisted marriage of warped flesh and
machine the Lang Scranton stabilizer was
anything but stable before his mind and
body became something else entirely the
doctor still had the presence of mind to
finally realize how he'd come to be in
this terrible place
the LSS had opened a wormhole known as a
Class C broken entry into a paradoxical
pocket Dimension between layers of
reality and taken him through it he'd
slipped through a crack in reality into
absolute darkness and now he was stuck
with a fate far worse than death how do
we know any of this much like the event
in the first place it's a total accident
testing Superior reality bending
technology almost six years after The
Disappearance caused the sudden Return
of the missing LSS to site-120's reality
labs
the only trace of Dr Scranton that it
brought back with it was the blood and
viscera that coded the console much to
the abject horror of his still grieving
wife Dr Anna Lang to this day Dr
Scranton formerly one of the
foundation's brightest Minds remains
trapped in the nightmare of
scp-3001 his current condition whether
the doctor is still alive after 20 years
of being warped by the low Hume field of
3001's dark and confines is still
unknown but for the doctor's own sake we
hope he's been dead for quite some time
because few things on Earth are as
horrifying as the alternative on an
ordinary day in 1991 a Young Man known
by the initials JS went on a hike with
four of his friends on the wooded
outskirts of their small town everything
seemed perfectly normal until JS began
to feel a strange sense of familiarity
like he had been in this spot before he
couldn't shake this weird feeling but
thought nothing more of it little did he
know that this was a sign of deadly
things to come several hours after first
experiencing that sense of deja vu JS
was found by the side of the road
covered in cuts and scratches with his
friends nowhere to be found this is the
story of scp-939 an unforgettable
monster that you'll never remember
there was no way for JS to know that the
unsettling feeling he felt and the
horrors that followed it were the result
of an experiment conducted by the SCP
Foundation an experiment with deadly
unforeseen consequences
JS and his friends were exposed to a
substance known only as amn c227 as part
of a series of tests performed by the
SCP Foundation intended to determine the
effectiveness of this substance as a
deliberate and knee stick
dealing with as many mysterious secret
creatures and objects as they do
the SCP Foundation has long needed a way
to tamper with the memories of those
exposed to the foundation's various
prisoners and test subjects and when the
foundation discovered amn c227 it seemed
like it might be perfect for this
purpose so where did amnc227 come from
over a year before the incident with JS
and his friends the SCP Foundation
captured
scp-939 scp-939 is a species of
endothermic predators that live and hunt
in packs their designated ketter class
and regarded as highly dangerous and
hostile to human life native to caves
they have no eyes translucent red skin
and stand at an average of 2.2 meters
tall with an average weight of 250
kilograms
they have four limbs each ending in
three fingered Claws and a fourth
opposable digit resembling a thumb
in addition to their sharp claws their
mouths are filled with red fang-like
teeth that reach up to six centimeters
in length
in place of their absent eyes they have
light sensitive spots running along
their backs
which are covered in spines believed to
detect changes in air pressure and flow
in addition to their many other
terrifying attributes the internal
anatomy of scp-939 poses a biological
mystery these creatures have no
circulatory system and no digestive
tract that's right in spite of being
Predators seemingly acting on a need to
feed they have no stomach instead when
they eat their food builds up in their
respiratory system until its presence
inhibits function and then it is
regurgitated in spite of being a
creature that should not under any
logical conditions be able to live
scp-939 continues to persist and is even
capable of giving birth to live young
after a gestation period of 12 months
the SCP Foundation was able to study a
litter of these young that were born in
captivity in September of 1992 though
the creatures remain just as much of a
scientific mystery as they were upon
first discovery
everything about them seems to defy the
logic of the natural world which to be
fair is really nothing new for the
foundation the respiratory system of
scp-939 was found to Exhale small traces
of an airborne amnestic substance given
the name amn c227 this compound blocks
the formation of memories for the
duration of exposure to it plus a
30-minute period following the exposure
give or take a few minutes it is
colorless odorless tasteless and
completely undetectable in the
bloodstream after only 60 Minutes amn
c227 was approved for use as a Class C
amnestic by the SCP Foundation in 1990
following some initial tests however
after one particular incident involving
a young man and his friends the official
use of amn c227 was suspended JS and
three of his four friends were
previously given a dose of amn c227
though the details of why they were
given the amnestic has since been
stricken from the record
several months after being exposed to
amnc227 JS and his friends went out on
their ill-fated hiking trip while hiking
JS was suddenly overcome with the sense
of deja vu when he mentioned it to his
friends three of them agreed that they
had felt it too one of the group another
young man who had not been exposed to
amnc 227 was uncomfortable and decided
to go home
JS and the remaining three members of
the group made the choice to stay in the
woods and try to determine what was
triggering the unusual feeling of
familiarity as they got closer and
closer to a large cave near the hiking
trail the sense of having been there
before grew stronger and stronger
armed with only one flashlight and a
foolish curiosity the four went inside
the cave
they made their way deeper and deeper
and deeper into the darkness not knowing
why they felt this way or what they
might find inside none of the group
could explain just what felt so familiar
only that the further they made their
way into the cave the more pronounced
the feeling became it was getting late
and they knew they should have been
afraid to venture so deep into a cave
with only one light source and no
knowledge of what lay inside but still
they pressed on one of the group
remarked that they should turn back but
the others refused to listen they wanted
to know what they were getting close to
what was drawing them deeper and deeper
into the cave unfortunately for them
they would get their answer in the heart
of the cave was a pack of scp-939
waiting patiently for their prey to
wander into their domain there are no
witnesses to account for what exactly
happened to JS and his companions but we
can reasonably piece the events together
from what happened after once the
friends reached the heart of the Cave
the creatures were on them in seconds
raking them with their sharp claws and
biting with their
scp-939 are larger and stronger than
most people so it was probably not much
of a fight however while his friends
were being devoured JS was somehow able
to scramble out of the cave and make his
way into the woods in search of help
under the influence of the AMC 227 that
had built up in the cave from the
presence of the pack of scp-939 JS lost
a large portion of his memory of the
event he found himself on the side of
the highway late at night seriously
injured and his clothes ripped an
officer found him there and asked him to
stay still and remain calm until an
ambulance could arrive JS was still in a
panic and attempted to run away from the
officer begging to be released so that
he could get away he babbled
incoherently about the color red
screaming over and over again about the
red though when prompted he could not
explain what the red he was screaming
about referred to his friends were not
with him just as the officer managed to
calm JS the ambulance arrived its
flashing red lights sent him into
another frenzy and he attempted to
escape custody claiming that the red
lights were going to get him the
official police report described JS as
perhaps being under the influence of a
powerful hallucinogen that he was just
having a bad trip but the SCP Foundation
knew better
the foundation conducted an interview
with JS about his experience and
determined that scp-939 was certainly
involved as part of their cover-up
effort they strongly implicated JS in
The Disappearance and the death of his
friends he was convicted of manslaughter
though the bodies of his friends were
never found it is rumored that the SCP
Foundation hired him on a prison work
release program and that he now works as
a member of the janitorial staff at one
of the foundations facilities
this incident led to the suspension of
the use of amn c227 as it revealed some
vital and disturbing information about
the compound side effects after the
exposure to amn c227 a person who found
themselves exposed to it again would
experience a sense of familiarity and
felt compelled to investigate the source
of this feeling essentially anyone
treated with amn c227 are not made aware
of the existence and danger of scp-939
would become a perfect victim primed to
be attracted to dens of scp-939 it is
likely that this side effect is not a
coincidence but rather a deliberate
hunting tactic designed to attract prey
that had somehow managed to escape with
no memory of their attack at the hands
of scp-939 this previous intended prey
would find themselves drawn to the same
Den or even a new one not knowing that
they were walking back into near certain
death while the SCP Foundation suspended
the use of amnc227 as a Class C amnestic
they did recruit a team of SC field
operatives to take advantage of this
side effect this team of operatives were
deliberately administered a dose of
amnc227 and briefed on its effects as
well as the dangers of following the
feeling of deja vu should its surface in
the field these infected officers were
essentially used as Bloodhounds relying
on any sense of unusual familiarity to
sniff out new dens of scp-939 so they
could be captured and contained by the
foundation
as far as we know this operation is
still ongoing today however now that the
foundation has a sufficient number of
specimens to study additional dens of
scp-939 that are discovered are ordered
to be immediately destroyed as for the
scp-939 still in captivity they are
contained in environmentally regulated
and negatively pressured cells with
walls of reinforced concrete the doors
to the cells are airtight to prevent the
leakage of any amn c227 and any
Personnel that interact with one of the
creatures is required to wear level C
Hazmat gear to avoid exposure and follow
decontamination procedures upon exiting
the cell all scp-939 have subdermal
tracking devices implanted to find them
in the event of Escape
only one scp-939 has given birth in the
time that the creatures have been in
captivity strangely scp-939 young look
indistinguishable from Human infants and
change their physical appearance at some
yet unknown Point as they age if any
more offspring are produced they will
immediately be separated from the parent
and studied all that we know is that
they are found in caves in the woods
outside of a small town it it could be
any town even yours so if you're ever
out hiking and struck with a sudden
feeling of deja vu
don't investigate don't get curious
just go home
it might just save your life what's in a
name ancient folklore and fairy tales
sometimes tell of the importance of
names that they can hold the power to
summon or vanish whether you buy into
the Superstition or not you'd be unwise
to ignore the power a name can have
especially if you ever dare to venture
into
scp-4000 why use your own name too many
times in this extra dimensional forest
and you may find that what walks out
isn't you at all at least once a year
the foundation leads an expedition into
scp-4000 to explore this keter class
Dimension but if you go down to those
woods today then you'd better follow the
rules remember the foundation has
implemented these guidelines for your
own safety and it's in your best
interests to follow them first and
foremost when referencing anything
inside scp-4000 be it a person place or
thing you cannot under any circumstances
use names or titles communication is key
when exploring scp-4000 and making use
of specific descriptors will deter any
adverse effect on your journey for
example you may want to refer to the
location of scp-4000 as the woods where
you need to speak carefully an apt
description for such a place of course
there is a reason the foundation doesn't
provide a handy flash card of
alternative descriptors for any
Personnel taking part in the annual
Mission into scp-4000 nothing found
there can be referred to with any
consistent name so it's perhaps
advisable to look over a thesaurus and
expand your vocabulary before visiting
scp-4000 as you'll need to come up with
a lot of different ways to refer to the
people and creatures around you but
don't worry the foundation will be able
to train you how to properly refer to
scp-4000 in both written and verbal
communication in a similar vein the
second rule states that no Personnel
member should respond to their own name
while in scp-4000 naturally you and your
fellow Expedition team will not be alone
in the forest you find yourselves in the
denizens of scp-4000 are perpetually
mutating creatures some appearing to be
trustworthy While others are hostile it
is for personnel members own safety that
no can consistent names or titles are
used to refer to each other in
conversation this has been known to
cause Personnel returning from scp-4000
to experience Vivid hallucinations and
in some instances has led to the
appearances of creatures found in
scp-4000 in our world thirdly when
interacting with the life forms residing
in scp-4000 Personnel are advised to
accept any gifts that they're offered
but are warned to under no circumstances
consume anything that is given to them
while inside the forest finally in above
all do not divulge any name nicknamed
code name Alias or any other personal
designation when interacting with any
native entities and disregard any
designator that an inhabitant of
scp-4000 attempts to assign to you
personnel must however remain courteous
in the presence of any native creature
of scp-4000 and treat these entities
with respect and formality access to
scp-4000 can only be achieved by
performing procedure 4000 Holloway a
ritual requiring a steady flame in an
indoor fireplace fueled by only or
organic kindlet Personnel are required
to combine the powdered bones of one
male lion one male red fox and a baleen
whale and cast these into the fire with
a personal possession holding strong
sentimental value to the staff member
performing 4000 Halloween next Personnel
are to add three feathers of a bird such
as a raven or Crow and must respond with
the correct counter phrases once the
fire begins to emit a voice if these
conditions are meant and the correct
response is given Foundation Personnel
will gain access to the entry point of
scp-4000 if any error is made during the
course of Performing procedure 4000
Holloway then under no circumstances
should this ritual be repeated staff are
urged to apologize for any incorrect
actions then refrain from engaging this
procedure in the future should procedure
4000 Holloway be completed successfully
Foundation Personnel will find
themselves arriving in the access point
to scp-4000 emerging from the mouth of
an old well in the center of the forest
exploration teams sent into scp-4000 are
advised that this Dimension does not
adhere to the laws of physical space
that Personnel will be accustomed to
there is a single confirmed safe route
that must be used when traversing The
Forest of scp-4000 a dirt path leading
in a circuit both beginning and
terminating at the entry point previous
attempts to map the landscape of
scp-4000 all confirmed that the only way
to safely exit this Dimension is to
follow the entire length of the path in
One Direction until eventually returning
to the well you have been warned any
attempt to travel back to the direction
you came in will result in a loss of
contact with the rest of the Expedition
team as mentioned scp-4000 is home to a
number of entities often noted to be
undergoing continuous and dramatic
changes in form these physiological
mutations appear to occur whenever these
creatures are unobserved making
distinguishing between them difficult
when questioned about the exact nature
of these changes the inhabitants of
scp-4000 claim to have no control over
them and expressed distress and
dissatisfaction when said changes occur
guidelines have been put in place by the
foundation regarding the interactions
between personnel and creatures found in
the forest and adhering to the rules
regarding the use of consistent names
and titles remains vitally important the
native creatures appear semi-humanoid
and are reported to be highly
temperamental should any staff member
happen to offend one of these natives
they may be subjected to anything from
verbal assault to acts of extreme
physical violence from the scp-4000
resident if any foundation Personnel
further question why there are so many
rules when visiting scp-4000 then they
need to look no further than the
discoveries and fate of Dr Eugene japers
who during his initial expedition to
scp-4000 in 2005 encountered a humanoid
native entity whose head resembled the
rabbits as the pair shared a polite
conversation the rabbit-like creature
made an inquiry regarding Dr japer's
name asking how was your name keeping to
the rules Dr japers did not divulge any
name or other form of title to the
creature at this time however japers
remained courteous and polite during the
interaction the rabbit responded with
the following are you simple I'm merely
asking how your name is my name has
smelt of raspberries like I think or
snapdragons perhaps it's so hard to tell
these days but one makes an effort in
his reply Dr japers made a reference to
his own name as having tasted rather
tart as of late before concluding the
conversation with the rabbit entity Upon
returning to the scp-40004 is three
years later Dr japers was met with the
same creature and once again engaged in
conversation with it after briefly
discussing their previous encounter Dr
chapers was able to turn their exchange
towards something the rabbit had
mentioned before about finding it
difficult to describe his own name when
asked to clarify this point the rabbit
replied I can only assume it's because
of how long we've been apart in my name
and I that is it's a good name a proud
name I'm fairly sure by this point
though it's probably decayed from its
former Grandeur if it even still exists
after this mention of its relationship
with its own name it should be noted
that the rabbit referred to Dr japers by
the title fellow scholar the third and
final encounter between Dr japers and
this entity came in 2013 after the
doctor was sent into scp-4000 with
instructions to conduct a more thorough
interview with the subject it was during
their third conversation that the rapid
man revealed details of a long forgotten
war between human beings and the
residents of scp-4000 apparently these
creatures the FAE do not originate from
the forest in which they now reside and
according to the rabbit man's claims
were born in our world much as it
Grieves me to say we were betrayed the
rabbit explained we had fought side by
side you know in the war against that
factory we had done nothing but help
them and what did they do they destroyed
us they took so many of our lives in all
of our names some of us fled here when
the war was just beginning but not many
not many still though I don't hate them
it has been assumed by some that the
foundation was directly involved in
whatever may have wiped out the FAE
causing them to either Retreat or be
banished to the forest of scp-4000 and
additional assumption has been made that
whatever weapons were used on these
creatures is directly responsible for
their constantly shifting State
rendering them without their own names
or identities whatever the case may be
it was during their conversation that Dr
japers in reference to their second
encounter referred to himself as a
fellow scholar to the rabbit in order to
coax information from him however in
doing so the doctor had unwittingly
accepted the title that the native
entity had given him by mistakenly
responding to the name fellow scholar
the doctor had broken the rules of
interacting with the creatures of
scp-4000 an easy mistake but a costly
one the doctor would later leave
scp-4000 traversing the safe path back
to the well and Dr J for Spanish shortly
after his exit from scp-4000 his
whereabouts are currently unknown the
foundation has made several attempts to
investigate his untimely disappearance
but to this day he remains missing and
the fur left on the inside of his
expedition gear displayed no strange
properties the single goal it would seem
of the creatures residing in scp-4000 is
the theft of names however this
naturally extends far beyond the
dimension's definition of identity theft
though an unfortunate blunder Dr chapers
allowed the friendly nature and demeanor
of the rabbit entity to trick him into
accepting the name fellow scholar by
giving Dr jabers a name the rabbit was
free to steal not only his name but his
very identity while it is unclear how
this transference is achieved by the
creatures it is due to the risk of this
that the foundation employs such strict
rules for any research team tasked with
traveling to the forest of scp-4000 make
no mistake names have more power than we
realize and this is evident in few
places more so than scp-4000 a pocket
Dimension where ever-changing survivors
of a forgotten Massacre exist as
identities alone remember a name is a
powerful thing whichever side of the
well you find yourself on your name
binds you to who you are but if your
name becomes someone else's then what
else of yours becomes theirs too it was
just a job you were meant to be mopping
floors and cleaning toilets at the
Johnston labs and pharmaceuticals
Research Center for minimum wage and you
are happy about it grateful for any kind
of employment you didn't even know that
the company signing your checks was the
SCP Foundation an organization dedicated
to securing and containing anomalies and
protecting human
from their negative effects at any cost
and today you're going to find out
exactly how steep that cost can be the
Johnston labs and pharmaceuticals
Research Center isn't actually a
research center at all it's a foundation
front business with a building solely
dedicated to the containment of a single
anomaly
scp-3280 but again you're just the
janitor it's not like they would bother
telling you what's being contained here
if it breaks out you won't even know
what's killing you until it's too late
it begins like most classic horror
stories on a dark and stormy night
you're mopping up a silent hallway
whistling a little tune to yourself when
rain starts hammering down on the window
next to you not long after you see a
bolt of lightning split the distant Sky
followed by an immense thundercrack soon
after you hear screaming and panicking
From Below frantic footsteps then the
flashing lights and Sirens use think
back to your employee orientation these
flashing lights and wailing Sirens can
only mean one thing Containment Breach
you run for it not even knowing what
you're running from you bring your mop
and bucket with you perhaps just out of
habit you seek refuge in the only place
in the facility that truly seems to
belong to you the broom closet the alarm
blares as you lock yourself in the
closet you're shaking with Terror and
can hear the screaming of your
colleagues you hear more noises running
scrambling a wet dripping sound gunshots
and then silence all this time you can't
help but wonder why isn't anybody coming
to help us after a while the only thing
you can hear is the rain and the distant
Thunder it's been hours you've only
managed to Stave off dehydration by
drinking the filthy water from the mop
sink but at least it seems like the
chaos outside has died down carefully
you open the door and peek out of the
closet Darkness but no detectable
movement now's your chance and you make
a break for it creeping down the hall
the dark hallway is suddenly lit up by
lightning and you can see that there are
bodies everywhere you step over the
corpse of Dr cothrone one of the few
scientists working here who actually
knew your name if you can make it to the
security office you might be able to
radio for help or maybe access a
computer terminal on the way to the
office you hear another horrific screen
start to echo through the complex before
it's cut off by a Thunderclap you have
to ignore it though and push on when you
enter the security room you see that the
head security officer Nichols is already
dead his body has been cut open from
neck to groin gutted the anomaly
whatever it is has already been here you
access the computer terminal and open
the file for
scp-3280 you're warned that as
janitorial staff you have level zero
clearance and as a result information
will be omitted from the files you
access it doesn't matter you press on
and open up the file both the object
class and the description have been
redacted you can only see the special
containment procedures they dictate that
3280 is to remain contained at the
Johnston labs and pharmaceuticals
Research Center until long-term
containment procedures can be drawn up
if the entity ever reaches Beyond
sub-level 2 the facility enters full
lockdown mode not even information is
allowed in or out of the facility as
this could result in an XK Class end of
the world scenario in other words nobody
is coming to save you the only other
information on the page is a picture of
a lightning storm much like the one you
find yourself in right now lightning
flashes in the hall you Dart around
paranoid knowing the anomaly could be
anywhere all you can hear now is the
quiet drip drip drip of blood coming
from the body of security officer
Nichols whatever this thing had done to
him looked painful you try to remember
him as he was in life and then a
revelation hits you a security officer
probably has a lot better clearance than
a janitor you feel around Nichols
mutilated torso until you find his key
card thankfully Nichols was the kind of
guy who'd write his password on the
underside of this card so he wouldn't
forget it you easily gain access to the
foundation servers with his login
credentials you now have level 2
security clearance the terminal gives
you the option to view security footage
taken throughout the site you're given
access to every camera still working
after the Containment Breach and the
subsequent Carnage you select the camera
feed for the second floor Barracks there
you see researcher Jensen hanging from a
makeshift news attached to his bunk
there's a puddle underneath his corpse
you access the feed from the second
floor east Wing there you see Dr
Emmanuel stumbling down a Corridor his
movements are oddly listless like he's
in the trance suddenly there's another
flash of lightning and a crack of
thunder Dr Emmanuel clutches his gut in
pain and crumples to the floor you
access the camera feed from the first
floor entrance it seems that the whole
area is flooded is this because of the
storm in a panic many lower tier staff
members had tried to escape defying the
lockdown protocols in the special
containment procedures now they're
floating face down in the water all dead
you access the camera feed from
sub-level 2 and see another corpse lying
in the corner he's wearing an orange
jumpsuit
class no idea why he was down there the
only other notable thing in the basement
was a burst pipe leaking and spraying
more water everywhere with trembling
fingers you select the camera feed for
the first floor cafeteria the whole room
is practically under water the only
evidence of the massacre that must have
taken place are the fragments of
clothing floating on the surface of the
water that and the fleshy pink slurry
forming at the bottom of the windows it
reminds you of the gooey meat runoff in
chicken nugget factories you close your
eyes and try to Center yourself it's
violent chaos looking at more of it
isn't getting you anywhere instead you
put those new level 2 security access
credentials to good use and hop back
onto the file for
scp-3280 you think to yourself there has
to be something I can use on here but
even as you wait for the file to load
some part of you knows that time is
running out for you perhaps it's the
stress or the fear or the filthy mop
water you drink but you're feeling the
pressure start to mount physically your
stomach is beginning to ache you can see
blurry shapes moving in the corners of
your eyes it's getting harder to focus
your vision and harder still to quiet
the terrified voices in your mind but
you can't get up not without knowing
what is doing this to you the
containment class for scp-3280 is now
Declassified Euclid and once more the
special containment procedures have
altered too they now explain that every
week a new member of d-class personnel
is to be deposited into the entities
layer in sub-level 2 through
Subterranean access point gamma the
d-class or more accurately the
sacrifices are to be told lies about why
exactly they need to descend to the
lowest point in the facility they're
even given a working flashlight and a
defensive night stick to create the
illusion that the foundation expects
them to ever return from the depths
little do they know they also have a
tiny transmitter sewn into their
jumpsuit this broadcasts a frequency
that will attract an eager scp-3280 to
the d-class's location like a dinner
bell only it can hear the file specifies
that scp-3280 always prefers live prey
well at least that explains the dead
d-class in sub-level 2. you think hoping
that it will somehow overwhelm the
dizziness you're feeling or the nagging
pain in your cut you read on somehow the
file's tone becomes even more severe it
says that failure to maintain the
containment of scp-3280 will not only
trigger a lockdown it will always call
in the intervention of two different
mobile task forces MTF Iota 12 the
silencers and tau-4 also known as water
water everywhere if 12 hours pass from
the point of initial Containment Breach
and the o5 council hasn't been given the
all-clear signal by one of these teams
preparation Begins for an dominant XK
Class end of the world scenario just
reading the words sends you into a cold
sweat end of the world what on Earth is
this creature finally you reach the
description you get to find out what
this horrifying entity actually is but
the last thing you expect is the first
sentence in the file to read
scp-3280 is a Sapient entity composed of
a fluid physically identical to water
capable of traveling roughly two and a
half kilometers per hour it's water it's
literally a living thinking blob of
water as you read on the concerning
details pile up any water that the
anomalous scp-3280 water touches it
integrates it into its own Mass but
anytime water is separated from this
Mass it remains anomalous and continues
to act independently when the creature
was first discovered it was a mere 66.4
liters in volume now it's around 20 500
the water infected by scp-3280 is
hostile to all humans and not just in
the defensive manner
scp-3280 will actively seek out human
prey and when it finds them it forces
its mass into any available body orifice
including the victim's pores this can
happen in such a subtle manner that you
may not even notice yourself being
infiltrated but below this the file has
a list of symptoms for those
experiencing 3280 infiltration loss of
motor control weakening of the
micturition reflex visual hallucinations
and abdominal pain as you read the words
your stomach gives another painful churn
almost like something is moving around
inside of you it's all coming together
you read on the file states that
scp-3280 is so difficult to contain
because it exhibits claustrophobic
Tendencies anytime it's placed inside a
container whether organic or inorganic
it escapes with pressure water jets that
travel at over 255 miles per hour if the
water is inside a human it may literally
explode out of them killing them in the
process your jittering eyes turn to the
gutted body of security officer Nichols
it all makes sense now everything is
becoming clear as the pain in your
stomach builds in its intensity the file
goes on to say that if scp-3280 escapes
sub-level 2 it may be impossible to
contain again if 3280 ever escaped the
site proper it would indeed cause an XK
Class end of the world scenario to
unfold as 3280 merged with our water
cycle and destroyed all of Humanity on a
global scale it would become truly
impossible for anyone to escape you
can't read anymore the pain in your
stomach is unbearable you jerk from your
seat and stumble out into the Hall
doubled over in agony you can feel it
pulsing in there fighting its way out it
must have gotten in through the filthy
mop water you were drinking you didn't
even know it but your fate has been
sealed for hours you've been a dead man
walking the hum of pain builds in your
ears and renders you almost death all
you can hear is the pattern of rain and
distant Thunder you collapse against the
glass feeling the coolness of it against
the skin of your face and in that moment
you see the water droplets on the window
pane reverse Direction they're
slithering up the glass towards your
face in defiance of gravity then you
realize it's all over and not just for
you
scp-3280 has escaped it's out there and
it's going to drown the entire world as
you collapse to your knees and prepare
to be torn apart from the inside your
final thought is that at least you won't
be alive to see it Ching Hai Lake the
largest lake in China is one of the most
secure locations the SCP Foundation has
ever taken control of all available
military assets have been gathered at
the site including three of the most
elite mobile task force units with
experimental Weaponry
scp-4290 must not be allowed to open and
the site has been surrounded by nuclear
mines and targeted with the dagas brake
orbital strike system the perimeter
cannot be breached even if it means the
complete annihilation of the entire area
this is considered to be an acceptable
loss for the foundation since the
destruction that would be caused by
taking such an extreme measure is far
from the worst case scenario when it
comes to
scp-4290 that's because the entity
contained with an
scp-4290 site has the potential to
create a true end of the world scenario
the foundation of course is no stranger
to such situations and even has a set of
designations for the various types of
apocalypses like CK class restructuring
scenarios and ZK Class end of reality
scenarios and since dealing with the end
of the world is nothing new for the
foundation certain precautions have been
taken at the 4290 site if containment
measures fail selected Foundation
personnel and civilians will be taken
into nearby Emergency Shelters that will
hopefully survive the chaos that would
occur following a breach and the
foundation assumed that there was a good
chance this plan would have to be used
at some point since at the time these
precautions were put in place it was
impossible to know the chance of
successful long-term containment but
just what is the entity that is held
within the site of
scp-4290 that is capable of causing so
Much Death and destruction on a major
scale they call it simply the child no
one has ever seen the child no one knows
what the entity is that's because even
setting aside all the foundation's
security the site itself is still deeply
protected literally over a hundred feet
below the surface of Ching Hai Lake a
stunning collection of relics can be
found the cytosthomatologically sealed
with eight massive metal totems made of
beryllium and bronze that resemble armed
Warriors the statues are inscribed with
ruins and arranged in a pattern designed
to banish The Entity kept there and keep
the seal on its prison closed
archaeological evidence indicates that
the site has been there for a very long
time and it is still active with the
center of the site periodically emitting
bursts of red light but lately the
bursts have suddenly started getting
brighter you may be wondering how we
know so much about
scp-4290 and that it's a site designed
to keep something sealed if it's been
deep in a lake quietly doing its job the
SCP Foundation has access to unusual
sources including
scp-1726 and it's from there that we
learned the little we know about
scp-4290
scp-1726 is a librarian China that
appears to only be one floor from the
outside but on the inside covers over 14
square kilometers in area it's full of a
seemingly Limitless amount of texts many
of which describe ancient and lost
civilizations along with some Clues as
to what led to the fall of these
cultures one text reveals the presence
of a terrible and apparently Unstoppable
enemy it was called the child but it was
anything but innocent when these texts
were translated what Foundation
researchers discovered terrified them
they described the emergence of a beast
with 10 terrible mouths and 20 arms
stretch wide it was attacked by an army
of Warriors but they were quickly
overwhelmed by what was described as
torrents of darkness and dead geometries
they were killed brutally and the child
used its skeletal fingers to unleash a
torrent of flame every soul in the
vicinity was consumed wax rained from
the sky and the child devoured
everything around it for 10 days as the
whole world tremble but then something
sealed the child away in its prison
which is now covered By the Waters of
Ching Hai Lake soon ominous signs began
to appear that the child would awaken
again though one day televisions in the
nearby area all suddenly stopped playing
their regular programming and began to
show images of
scp-4290 with a mysterious voice coming
on over the images saying repair the
child's locks this became more and more
frequent and the tone of the voice
became more worried eventually saying
there is little time left further
investigations of the location revealed
the location of the mysterious mechanism
that kept the chamber sealed which was
designated as
scp-4290 lock but how do you repair a
device that is eons old and should you
even be fixing it when the one telling
you to do so is a mysterious disembodied
voice that only appears on pirated
television broadcasts the foundation
scrambled to to find any information
they could and they were able to find
clues about the history of
scp-4290 referenced in other texts lost
civilizations like the Shah Dynasty the
urchins and the ancient orthonians had
apparently strengthened the seals during
their own Reigns but the most
significant findings indicated a
connection to one of the most terrifying
entities the SCP Foundation had ever
contained and one of the most
unpredictable the David Empire this
mysterious war-like civilization has
only been known through one source
scp-140 a single hard copy book titled A
Chronicle of DeVos this is a strange
anomalous book that is Written in Blood
and is able to add more pages
spontaneously to itself whenever it
comes in contact with any fluid that can
be used for writing but seems to
especially prefer human blood it
recounts the history of this
civilization and their many brutal
conquests while there was no proof of
the DeVos before the book was found
found evidence paralleling the events
written in the book is now being found
in archaeological digs more dangerously
as more pages appear in the book the
events of the Devi Empire are moving
closer to present day with them
currently appearing in the book as
having existed until 270 CE the DeVos
were a bloodthirsty brutal race of
Warriors but there was one thing even
they were afraid of the child the DeVos
had performed the last successful ritual
of sacrifice needed to strengthen the
lock not long before they're currently
described destruction and the book
contained enough detail to recreate the
ritual but SCP researchers would find
that performing it would not be for the
faint of heart the ritual required three
human cadavers not a problem for an
organization that's normal day-to-day
operation results in the loss of
multiple lives and the live Heart Of An
Angel the description of the ritual said
that the materials would be presented
new ruins should be carved into of the
totems the items would then vanish when
the ritual was completed and the lock
would somehow be renewed by this it
wasn't much to go on but time was
running out the foundation's department
of occult containment quickly sprang
into action assembling the materials and
placing them in the correct formation
while it was not safe to descend that
deep underwater to perform the ritual
manually technology could fill the role
a fleet of remotely operated
submersibles equipped with carving
material would carry the materials and
perform the ritual without any human
hands needed one of the red bursts
occurred Midway through the ritual
causing radiation damage to the vehicles
runes that have been carved in the past
were also damaged and the ritual was
interrupted while it seemed like it
might have been enough to activate the
site it wasn't perfect and when the
ritual was complete one of the three
cadavers in half of the Angel Heart were
still present at the site had it been
enough to satisfy the ritual and reseal
the lock there was nothing to do but
wait and see they wouldn't have to wait
bong for their answer as the mysterious
Voice once again took over the
televisions in the area this time its
message was less friendly the sacrifice
did not reach the ten Mars brace the
child apparently was not satisfied and
the lock was not sealed everyone feared
it was too late to prevent what was
coming and panic was starting to spread
among the ranks one day several
Personnel stationed at the Ching Hai
lake side broke protocol and fled none
of them were ever found but one fugitive
staff member an agent Zenovia marinos
left behind a note though it read do we
think we can actually stop this no
civilization before us wanted to fight
the child none of them the sacrifices
won't work anymore it refuses to consume
them they aren't enough to satiate it
once the seal breaks will have a world
of molten darkness and the child will be
all that's left eating drinking your
fools for staying agent marinos was
apparently so scared that she had fled
through a portal to an extra dimensional
space in order to escape there would be
no point in trying to track her even if
she was still alive but in our own
Dimension time was running out
Foundation seismologists were brought to
the site and stationed outside and began
monitoring the high energy pulses coming
from behind the log the energy was
reportedly strong enough to alter
dimensions and the pulsing red light now
covered the entire ceiling site growing
stronger and stronger as the totems
started degrading at an alarming rate
the foundation stood on guard for
whatever was about to emerge but no one
knew if they had any chance against
whatever it was on August 18th the
totems fully disintegrated some of the
foundation's best military forces
gathered on the shores of the lake and
waited ten minutes later something
massive emerged phase out of the lock
and onto the seabed and did it move the
assembled Foundation forces were
confused and continued to observe the
creature and after no activity he was
seen after three hours the authorization
was given for submersibles and a small
exploratory team to proceed down to the
seabed for an up close investigation
there down on the floor of the lake was
the child it was as terrifying as
described with a countless mouths and
arms and huge in size over 40 meters
long the signs of previous rituals were
everywhere with angel hearts and human
corpses littered around some in the
creature's mouth but none of them had
been eaten the ritual had apparently
been performed many times but to no
actual purpose the massive being was
scanned many times but no sign of
psychic energy radiation or other life
signs were detected the child was dead
and it had apparently been so for a very
very long time once the area had been
cleared teams were brought in to
investigate the body in person and
perform an autopsy on the sun no
explanation of what exactly this
creature had been what its Origins were
has ever been discovered but they did
get answers for when it died the time of
death was roughly 9 000 years ago not
long after its initial ceiling the cause
of death was discovered too the child
destroyer of worlds and Scourge of
countless civilizations had died from
malnutrition whatever this thing had
been it had been sealed away and had
died from a hunger not long after one
civilization after another had continued
to perform the rituals to keep its Seal
never aware that it was no longer a
threat with this new discovery
scp-4290 was reclassified as neutralized
but the child taught us all a valuable
lesson about being prepared for
potential world-ending scenarios and the
foundation continues to stand on alert
for any more entities from the distant
past that may pose a threat today
because who knows what else is sealed
away at the bottom of a lake abandoned
mine or in the ocean's deepest trenches
there might just be an other existential
threat to humanity that's just waiting
for a chance to emerge and help us all
if it remembered to pack a lunch a
pickaxe shatters the rocky wall of a
mine shaft hundreds of feet below the
Earth it's 1871 in a place that will
later be known as Columbia County
Pennsylvania men performing
back-breaking labor their hands and
faces blackened with dirt all working in
pursuit of that immensely valuable Rock
Cole it's the fuel for the booming
Industrial Revolution and much like how
dragons were said to guard gold this
more modern treasure pointed to an even
more terrifying monster a monster that
the SCP Foundation would someday come to
know as
scp-1179 but these unfortunate and
underpaid miners had no idea what they
were about to discover one of the men
working there that day Rob O Dwyer was
hammering away at the wall in front of
him when he heard something strange was
that an go behind the Rocks this could
mean only one thing the rocks in front
of them were Hollow there had to be some
kind of space hiding behind them O'Dwyer
struck again and again at the Rocks in
front of him until the barrier finally
tumbled away he and the other miners
suddenly felt a gust of cool ancient air
from the vast and darkened Cavern in
front of them sweeped through the mine
they felt like they were standing on the
edge of something truly otherworldly as
they lifted their safety lamps high and
crept carefully into the dark it dawned
on them that they were likely the first
human beings to ever set foot here but
that didn't mean something non-human
hadn't gotten there first o'dwyer's lamp
soon found something in the dark a huge
figure curled into a crouching position
hiding its face it was made from Stone
like an enormous yet incredibly detailed
statue of something Almost Human but not
quite the Petrified thing had two great
horns on either side of its head
twisting into Spa virals like that of a
huge RAM word of the giant Frozen
Monster hidden in the bottom of the mine
soon made its way back to the foreman
and then back to the mine's owner one
Sean O'Malley if it were anyone else
perhaps this news would have been taken
to the Press immediately and the
foundation would have taken control of
the situation just as quickly but Mr
O'Malley was no ordinary mining magnet
he was a member of the Molly Maguires an
irish-american secret society whose
members were predominantly coal miners
in Pennsylvania Sean and the other Molly
McGuires dubbed this anomaly the
sleeping Stone Giant and conspired to
keep it a secret between them as secret
societies have a habit of doing though
the Molly Maguires were disbanded less
than a decade later they were all sworn
to secrecy on the Giant's resting place
until of course a descendant of Sean
O'Malley his grandson Ian O'Malley was
chosen as a prospective agent of the SCP
Foundation the foundation doesn't just
let anyone join their ranks they perform
an extensive background check on all
prospective agents both to find out that
they're capable of rising to the
challenges of the job and also to detect
any affiliation to enemy groups of
Interest it was during this background
check that O'Malley's Subterranean
Family secret was discovered and the
land above the old mine shaft was bought
up by a front company owned by the
foundation the sleeping Stone Giant was
finally incapable hands and in keeping
with standard procedure a research site
was built above the giant to gather data
and keep an eye on things at the time
the anomaly was considered extremely low
risk its containment file read
scp-1179 is apparently dormant encased
in the Bedrock under research site apart
from simple monitoring and standard
research safety protocols no additional
containment is deemed necessary at this
time but of course those simple
containment procedures would soon need
updating in 1962 the the town of
Centralia Pennsylvania had a trash
problem there were eight illegal trash
dumping sites across the town and to
combat this issue the Town Council
opened up a huge landfill in an
abandoned mine shaft you'd think this
would be enough for the moderately sized
town but humans have a tendency to
produce a lot of trash and they soon
filled up the new landfill too in order
to address the issue the town decided to
do a controlled burn of some of the
garbage it should have been simple
enough but those who lit this garbage
fire didn't follow proper safety
procedures and ended up accidentally
igniting a seam of anthracite coal this
was like lighting the fuse to the
world's largest stick of dynamite and
fire soon cores through the long
abandoned mine tunnels when the fireball
finally reached the sleeping Stone Giant
in this dark pit the Beast woke up in
that instant an otherwise uneventful day
quickly became a brutal bloodbath
researchers walking through the base
felt a monstrous rumbling beneath them
heat sensors were burning up in seismic
readings were off the scale something
was climbing up towards them suddenly an
impossibly large sword speared its way
out of the floor killing everyone around
it with an immense blast of heat the
newly awakened monster went on an
underground Rampage almost completely
destroying the research base and killing
nearly everyone inside before retreating
into the honeycomb of coal mines and
caverns in the area igniting even more
anthracite coal fires the foundation
needed to step in before things really
got out of control at present the
foundation couldn't properly administer
standard area construction protocols for
cutter class scps so they instead
designated the mines caverns and
surrounding Countryside as area 179 and
dispatch mobile task forces to try and
contain the Beast rampaging in the
Centralia mines but much like the fire
that started this whole mess the Beast
proved much harder to control than
initially imagined all five of the
expeditionary teams sent to a happy him
the monster failed and many team members
were slaughtered in the process from the
terrifying accounts of the survivors we
have a vague idea of the nature of the
Beast below no pictures of the creature
exist in exact descriptions on the Beast
can vary whether this is because the
Beast frequently shapeshifts or because
it has some kind of Cognito hazardous
effects on those who view it is unclear
the most frequently reported
characteristics of the creature are its
immense height and the extreme heat that
its body exudes many report that the
creature's body seem to be formed of a
mix of hardened lava pure fire and
burning smoke the Beast measures over 30
meters from head to toe with shoulders
over 8 meters wide it's commonly said to
have two huge ram-like horns and a
weathered bearded face the Beast has
been compared by some to the Norse
mythological figure sierder the giant
guarding the frontier of the Norse fire
realm of moosebell however the actual
age of the creature seems to predate
these Legends by considerable margin
dating of the stratum encasing scp-1179
indicates it dates to the Mississippian
sub-period of the Carboniferous period
approximately
359.2 to
318.1 million years ago this age is
consistent with the geological age of
this region so it may have literally
come with the territory less common
descriptions of the bees claim that it
has huge Wings eyes made of Hellfire and
fangs as long as a man's arm some say
that the Beast has neither horns nor
fangs and its face is encircled By
Flames which reach down into a long
beard of fire and like a certain
creature known as the balrog that Lord
of the Rings fans will be very familiar
with this Beast comes with weapons in
one hand the Beast wields a giant
burning sword around 5 meters in length
in the other it wields a huge
multi-tailed Whip made out of fire it's
incredibly proficient with these weapons
too and as a serious strategic advantage
in its underground environment
Foundation researchers have determined
that some of the wounds the beasts
gained from its first confrontation
haven't fully healed implying the Beast
could in theory be destroyed with enough
Firepower however given that the Beast
has killed almost everyone who faced it
and its mere presence can start almost
uncontrollable fires direct engagement
would only be used as a last resort even
the creature's breath can be extremely
dangerous chemical analysis of air
samples taken from
scp-1179's breath have shown
exceptionally high concentrations of
carbon monoxide and sulfur dioxide the
very presence of this creature creates a
real and active danger to everyone
around it and the beast's presence was
beginning to have seriously negative
effects on the people up above by the
1970s the foundation had given up on
sending mobile task forces into the
caverns and instead began to focus on
depopulating the town of Centralia to
prevent further fatalities from the
Press sense of
scp-1179 the Subterranean activities of
the creature were causing collapses in
some areas and noxious fumes were
beginning to Rise Up from cracks in the
ground as the constant raging fires burn
beneath the Earth they were causing
everything above to slowly melt or bake
a foundation geologist determined that
the fires created by the Beast would
likely remain active for 250 years and
any attempts to put out the fires or
contain the bees would ultimately be
futile this led to the formation of
project Tartarus a concerted effort to
cover up
scp-1179 and fully Evacuate the citizens
of Centralia they pushed the narrative
that the mine fires while deadly were
merely the result of the failed garbage
burning plan and little by little the
people of Centralia began to move away
by 1984 the United States government
finally caved to secret lobbying from
the foundation and allocated funds in
excess of 42 million dollars to relocate
the remaining civilian in residents from
the area any legal complaints from
Centralia residents were quietly crushed
by the foundation and efforts to remove
pretty much all residents from the area
were successful this allowed the
foundation to finally cast a wider net
and administer kettier-class containment
protocols around the two kilometer
underground Zone where
scp-1179 resides the foundation has
continued studies on the bees from Below
in the decades since with some
scientists even suggesting it could be
used to produce geothermal energy but
whether or not that would actually be
feasible remains unknown for now
scp-1179 seems content to stay within
its own and hopefully it stays that way
but as we're forced to dig deeper and
deeper for the remaining precious metals
here on Earth there's no telling what
new dangers we might find lurking far
below the ground it was 1948 in Villa
Blanca Guatemala has night fell two
young boys Carlos and Miguel played a
game of soccer in the street it was a
quiet town full of humble hard-working
people and they were about to come face
to face with a monster typically when
something like this happened you'd know
exactly who to call the SCP Foundation
problem is while these days we can
generally depend on the hard-working
agents and researchers of the foundation
to save us from any anomalous
Supernatural threats with their tactics
expertise and Equipment it wasn't always
this way there was a time before the SCP
Foundation became the Titan of anomaly
combating prowess it is today and it's
that time that we're focusing on today
it all comes back to a strange and
violent creature wandering the darkened
streets of Guatemala or as Dr Charles
Ogden gears proposed we call it
scp-001 the Prototype
scp-001 is a topic that we've covered in
a number of videos but even then we can
never quite capture the full scope of
this Wiley designation what is scp-001
is probably one of the most loaded
questions you can possibly ask a member
of the SCP Foundation and it may be your
last as the majority of the files Under
the scp-001 Umbrella are highly
classified for pretty much everyone
under level 5 clearance
001 covers a large number of potentially
anomalous items entities and Concepts
from the dreaded Scarlet King to the
awe-inspiring gate Guardian to the very
SCP Foundation itself through the eyes
of the charmingly incompetent unusual
incidence unit of the FBI perhaps
they're all real perhaps only one of
them is and the rest are in there as a
smoke screen perhaps they're all fake
red herrings laid down to hide the trail
to something even more secretive and
fantastic all we know is that 001 seem
to be gathered around a collection of
loose themes the beginnings of the
foundation events or entities that could
end the foundation or even the world and
key formative moments in the
foundation's History Dr Gear's proposal
for scp-001 lies firmly in the latter
camp and if you keep watching and
listening closely you'll see exactly why
back to Carlos and Miguel the pair of 11
year olds playing football on the quiet
back streets of villablanca they were
kicking the ball back and forth when
they heard a strange screeching noise in
the distance at first they thought it
was some kind of injured bird squawking
desperately for health being good kids
they didn't waste a second running into
the action heading further into the
outskirts of town however the creature
they encountered on that Rural Road was
certainly no bird when they first saw it
hunched over a few meters in front of
them they thought it must have been a
horribly injured man he was deadly thin
with gray brown skin that looked either
bruised or burned it was twitching and
weeping its chest heaving in heavy
labored pants it's lit limbs were
jerking wildly as though the creature
was being electrocuted hey mister are
you okay Carlos called out in Spanish in
that moment what they had wrongly
thought was a man just froze up finally
registering their presence immediately
the two boys knew something was wrong as
the creature slowly Rose to its full
height well over six feet towering over
the two of them even at a distance they
noticed something was wrong with its
limbs they were too long well out of
proportion with its human-sized torso it
didn't have hands and feet at least not
in the way that humans do instead its
slender ankles terminated in long black
spikes and its wrists each split off
into three equally black claws but worst
of all was its face if you could even
call what that monster had a face its
head was split in the middle by a huge
mouth at first its gnarly lips were
pursed but they soon slid open with a
low rumbling Roar the boys could feel
their knees shaking as they saw the
monster's mouth full of long rotten
fangs something started sliding up the
dark passage of the monster's throat a
translucent milky blue sphere was that
thing an eye it made the two boys feel
sick to even look at it that's when the
eyes started to glow and the space
around the monster began to Shimmer
slightly like some kind of terrible
sorcery as the two boys felt a strange
Force pulling at them trying to tug them
into the creature's Embrace they were
suddenly jogged from their frightened
paralysis and decided to finally make a
run for it there was no doubt about what
had just happened they'd encountered a
demon in the flesh intent on taking
their souls straight to hell when the
two of them told their parents they were
met at first with disbelief two young
boys saw something that frightened them
in the dark perhaps an animal if
anything at all and they'd let their
imagination run wild it was typical of
children however things didn't seem
quite so simple when more sightings
started popping up people all across the
town of Villa Blanca started seeing this
monster all with matching descriptions a
huge emaciated Beast with a mouth for a
face its glowing blue eye nested inside
the natural excuses circulated that
first perhaps the creature was a local
prankster in a costume this would be
comforting to believe but how many
pranksters and costumes can completely
disappear before your very eyes the
monster's eye would glow and just like
that it would simply vanish as fear and
paranoia began spreading through the
town people suggested that perhaps it
was a case of mass hysteria fear and
panic taking over rationality but by
this point things had gotten worse
Carlos and Miguel the two boys who'd
first discovered the demon on the back
road had become sick they were
experiencing severe nausea vomiting
headaches and diarrhea their bodies weak
second lesions began developing on their
skin as their conditions deteriorated
and it seemed as though nobody was
capable of treating them a rumor spread
that the monster was somehow inducing
this sickness the town doctor didn't
have the expertise to diagnose it but
the boys were suffering from acute
radiation sickness and they wouldn't be
the only ones many of the people who'd
reported sightings and close encounters
with the monsters started coming down
with severe radiation sickness to the
town's people it just seemed to be a
demon spreading some invisible plague
among them but the horrors wouldn't stop
there it seemed that this demon also
liked to take a more direct approach to
harming the townsfolk because not long
after the sickness broke out people
started disappearing there were never
any bodies the most that would ever be
found were tattered items of clothing
left at the site of the disappearances
or blood smeared across the walls or
ground before they knew it seven of
their people were gone it seemed aimed
that for all intents and purposes God
had abandoned them they were playthings
of the demon now thankfully for the
town's folk who weren't yet irradiated
or vanished an organization was forming
one that might be their only chance at
Salvation someday in the future it would
become known as the SCP Foundation but
it had a lot to learn before it got
there you see the reason that this
iteration of scp-001 is known as the
Prototype is that if Dr gears is to be
believed it may be the first anomalous
entity that they ever truly faced so
naturally getting the creature captured
and contained didn't go quite as
smoothly as most of their modern jobs
despite the comparative Simplicity of
this old threat General machoy an
ex-military operator that became part of
what will once again call the precursors
to the foundation letter research and
Recovery team into Villa Blanca to hunt
down and retrieve the Beast that had
been causing all this misery and death
among the townsfolk however this proved
to be easier said than done while its
bestial appearance might fool people
into thinking the monster was just a
Mindless animal later writings on the
creature would describe it as both
incredibly cunning and terrifyingly fast
when a group of armed Personnel first
tried to engage the creature directly
they had no idea that they were walking
right into the middle of a bloodbath
they believed they had it surrounded on
another rural Back Road advancing with
assault rifles when the creature flipped
out and started killing them the
Prototype proved to have frightening
offensive capabilities its three dark
claws easily carved through the armor of
the soldiers trying desperately to
contain it the creature moved so fast
that none of them could reliably draw a
beat on it and if any of them could it
was holding their severed head before
they had a chance to squeeze the trigger
but death by the creature's claws was
one of the more pleasant ways it could
kill its victims at one point during an
engagement with precursor troops it
opened its mouth and unveiled its
glowing blue eye at this point one of
the soldiers screamed and suddenly
seemed to be sucked inside of himself
completely disappearing the prototype's
blue eye glowed again and it once again
just teleported away from the scene a
number of soldiers who survived this
altercation later needed to be treated
for acute radiation sickness researchers
eventually managed to figure out what
was actually happening with the creature
it had the ability to manifest micro
singularities tiny black holes that are
used to both teleport from place to
place and defend itself from attacks
when necessary these singularities
wouldn't stick around for long a few
seconds at most but they had the
terrifying side effect of putting out
massive amounts of radiation this is why
it was making so much of the town and
the recovery team sick via mere
proximity thankfully in finding out the
creature's strength they also managed to
find out its weaknesses its powers were
dampened by high humidity bright lights
and especially intense strobing lights
it was through the use of these lights
that the creature was finally captured
and brought into adrx 19 a complex that
would later become site-19 for
containment there its containment
procedures were devised by one of the
burgeoning organization's top Minds Dr
Herman ketter however Dr ketter would
sadly never actually live to see the
duration of the prototype's containment
at adrx 19. he was tragically killed by
the monster though his name would live
on as the designation for anomalies that
were particularly difficult to contain
it was thanks to him that his co-workers
realized lead-lined walls a reinforced
steel door a 100 humidity environment
and the frequent application of
high-intensity strobe lights were the
best way to keep the Prototype locked up
for good to this day this iteration of
scp-001 is a fascinating reminder that
the SCP Foundation wasn't always the
Juggernaut it is today there was once a
time where they had as little idea of
what they were doing as the rest of us
there's no better representation of this
than the file itself it was an era
before object classes and conventional
designation numbers the file is written
in a sketchy disorganized Manner and
arranged into item designation number
warning description of item detail of
current containment report and addendum
as with any experience in life it's
always worth asking what can we learn
from the SCP foundation's experience
with its possible first anomaly a
monster that seems almost nostalgically
quaint by today's standards perhaps the
greatest message is that everything is a
work in progress it was only by
determination and persistence that the
foundation could go from an organization
challenged by a monster like the
prototype to going Toe to Toe with real
Heavy Hitters like the Scarlet King how
very inspirational we have always been
afraid of the dark ancient ancestors of
mankind built fires to chase the Shadows
away to keep the thick black mystery of
night from encroaching on their fragile
little homes with all of the teeth and
Claw closet head within its depths from
the time we were small children we knew
to be nervous when the lights went out
we beg our parents to leave the hall
light on or plug in a nightlight praying
that a tiny sliver of Illumination will
protect us from the monsters we just
know are salivating beneath the bed
scratching against the closet door
waiting for us to close our eyes we pull
the blankets tight over our heads
heating the air with our panicked
breaths and reminding ourselves that the
shadow in the corner of the room was
just a rocking chair or a coat rack we
pretend it's the truth but there's a
reason we fear the darkness as much as
we do it's inherent it's a Memory passed
down from generation to generation ever
since we first learned how to scream as
adults we try to tell ourselves we've
outgrown those childish fears and night
terrors we know better now but you still
run up the darkened staircase as if
something's chasing you and your heart
jumps into your throat when you hear a
sound after midnight call it el Cucuy
the cloud the boogeyman or a thousand
other names we all know there is
something lurking in the dark and it
knows us too d-class 080-1 was pulled
from his cell one afternoon and brought
to a containment chamber he knew the
drill by now they would send him in and
he would encounter something bizarre
horrible and potentially deadly maybe he
would emerge traumatized maybe he would
lose a limb or maybe he would never come
back out at all a security guard opened
the door and instructed him to enter it
wasn't an ideal situation but he really
didn't have much of a choice and so he
walked inside Dr Smith called to him
from outside the room asking him what he
could see inside it was Pitch Black and
he couldn't see a thing and he told the
doctor as much but then
the hairs on the back of his neck
prickled a chill rippled down his spine
he had the distinct feeling that
something was looking right at him
watching waiting did you just let
something in here he asked it feels like
something's watching me no d080-1 Dr
Smith responded we did not let anything
into the room the man's hands were
shaking and he could feel sweat beating
on his forehead that couldn't be true he
wasn't alone in there there in the
corner there was a black mass large and
somehow even darker than the rest of the
room he could feel its eyes on his
boring into him his heart flooded in his
chest and he felt like he might be sick
he tried to take a step back but his
ankle folded under him and he collapsed
onto the floor what do you see Dr Smith
asked the man struggled to find the
words the
the giant Blackness like someone's just
standing in the corner oh God it's
looking right at me let me out he
climbed to his feet and he felt his way
along the wall until he reached the door
and began to pound against it with his
fists the doctor refused to let him out
until he described the being's
appearance it looks like a figure
hunched in the corner is it human Dr
Smith asked though he knew it was too
dark for the doctor to see he shook his
head ah no it's too big to be a human
it's still looking at him he docks still
staring though he should have had
adrenaline pumping through his body he
felt suddenly sleepy almost unable to
keep his eyes open move closer to it Dr
Smith ordered the d-class obeyed though
he swayed on his feet as he walked its
eyes look like
paper just staring at me and he wants me
to do something at this point he fell to
the ground again suddenly silent Dr
Smith called out to him again and again
but the man did not respond when the
research team opened the containment
chamber several minutes later
d-080-1 was gone he was lost to the
thing that Waits For Us in the dark he
was lost to a cp080 this was the first
in a series of tests that a foundation
research team headed by Dr Smith
performed in order to better understand
this shadowy figure and determine
whether or not it has a physical body of
any kind when the results were
determined to be unsatisfactory another
experiment was conducted a woman
referred to as
d-080-2 was selected and sent into the
room this time they would attempt to
have the d-class touch the entity upon
entering the chamber d080-2
marked on how dark it was and how
difficult it was to see anything inside
after several minutes however she
noticed something standing in the room
when prompted the only descriptor she
could give was that the entity had two
eyes Dr Smith asked her to approach The
Entity and Report any changes as she got
closer she became increasingly drowsy
and exhausted when she reached out to
touch scp-080 she went quiet and did not
respond to any additional questions she
was found asleep in the corner of the
containment room and was immediately
examined by medical staff no adverse
physical effects were found and an
interview was conducted to determine if
there was any residual psychological
impact in her interview
d080-2 was noticeably distant her
expression and tone of voice both
described as spaced out when asked about
her encounter with the entity she became
increasingly upset and began to
hyperventilate she screamed it just
stared and stared not moving but I felt
something I was on the floor and they
were all over me they're here no they're
trying to take me away back to the that
thing I won't go back you can't make me
go back in there at this point she
lunged across the table and attempted to
attack Dr Smith she was removed from the
interview room and later terminated a
third experiment was conducted using a
man referred to as
d-080-3 in order to counteract the
entity's tranquilizing effects he was
given a powerful amphetamine at a dose
that would keep a person under ordinary
circumstances awake for at least 36
hours when he entered the room like all
the others
d-080-3 saw shadowy figure standing in
the middle of the room he was told to
stand still and watch the figure and
Report anything unusual that he might
notice after 10 minutes the subject
became frightened and demanded to be let
out of the room he pounded on the door
and attempted to wedge it open when he
failed to open the door he lunged at
scp-080 and attempted to hit it with his
fists he promptly slumped on the floor
and went silent his dead body was found
in the room after the experiment and the
nautopsy determined the cause of death
to be a severe heart attack the
researchers who entered to retrieve the
body felt unsettled as they did so
reporting a feeling that scp-080 was
looking directly at them the entire time
following the conclusion of these
experiments the research team was able
to draw several conclusions about
scp-080 it causes debilitating
drowsiness in anyone who enters its
containment chamber after 30 minutes of
exposure anyone who is observing The
Entity will involuntarily fall into
remsley if there is any light in the
room brighter than a standard children's
night light The Entity will disappear
this should be treated as a Containment
Breach if and when this occurs after
conducting their experiments Dr Smith
and his research team began to
experience highly upsetting dreams while
many of the staff began requesting
appointments with the medical team Dr
Smith refused to discuss the nature of
his dreams with any on-site
psychologists insisting that he wasn't
going to let some silly nightmares get
the better of him as the weeks wore on
however he became increasingly withdrawn
his colleagues noted dark circles under
his eyes and noticed his near-constant
consumption of coffee that far surpassed
anything they had seen from him before
he seemed as if he was terrified of
falling asleep one day the exhaustion
caught up to him and he fell asleep at
his desk everyone in the building heard
his screams and won a security guard
eventually shook him awake his throat
was so raw from crying out in Terror
that he was coughing up Globs of blood
Dr Smith begged to be given an amnestic
to help him forget what he had dreamed
about forget all his dreams but his
request was denied he was placed on an
indefinitely of absence and sent home
two days later the research team was
given a somber report Dr Smith had leapt
off a bridge following Dr Smith's tragic
demise the rest of his staff were given
notebooks and encouraged to keep dream
journals during the course of their
research in order to track the
psychological impact of studying scp-080
additionally they were required to turn
these journals into site psychologists
for review particularly if the dreams
became especially disturbing or violent
the following are excerpts from some of
these dream journals research assistant
Megan Vaughn last night I dreamed I was
lying in my bed not my bed now in my
apartment but my childhood bed with the
baby pink sheets and the quilt my
grandmother made it felt so real every
detail my dollhouse in the corner my big
teddy bear my tea set and my closet I
was lying on my side with my head facing
my closet I used to be so scared of that
closet every night I would saw until my
dad checked it for Monsters I couldn't
go to sleep until he did but in my dream
I knew he hadn't checked and I just knew
there was something in there waiting for
me to close my eyes so I didn't I just
stared at that closet door and I waited
for it to open I started hearing this
scraping noise like dragging something
sharp across a wooden surface over and
over and over again but the door didn't
budge no matter how long I stared at it
all the while the noise just kept going
scrape scrape and the sound of soft
raspy breathing the closet stayed shut
eventually I rolled onto my back and
there it was on my ceiling hanging over
me with its upside down head and round
open mouth an old woman with long
stringy hair and fingernails as long as
my arms she was scratching on the
ceiling and waiting for me to look I
couldn't move I could just stare up at
her as she took two of those long long
fingernails and slowly them towards my
eyes and then I woke up I'm scared if I
go back to sleep she'll pick up right
where she left off Dr Owen Coley I'm
swimming in my family's Pond and it's a
beautiful sunny day outside I can feel
the sun's heat on my skin in the crisp
cold water cooling it every time I dip
under the surface I decide to swim down
towards the bottom and die for rocks and
when I come back up Suddenly It's stuck
it's the middle of the night and the
water doesn't look so clear anymore I
can't see the bottom I can't see
anything around me at all feel something
Slither against my leg I can't get away
but I just feel something else on my
other side slimy and quick I can't see
it but I can feel that it's much bigger
than me so I start swimming towards the
edge trying to get out before something
worse happens and I feel this sharp pain
like 100 needles stabbing into my back
and it hurts so bad I see red but I keep
swimming I reach the edge and I try to
pull myself out but I I can't there's
something on me it's so heavy I can't
get out I look over my shoulder and I
can now make it out it's the biggest
leech I've ever seen and it's latched
onto me I can see it pulsing swallowing
it's draining me I feel so weak all of a
sudden dizzy looked out of my hands and
they're shriveling up right there my
fingers pruning as I feel the blood
being pulled out of me my vision blurs
up and my head tips back and I'm sinking
down into the water as the leech keeps
sucking pulls down into the muck at the
bottom and everything just goes dark
researcher Kathy Levine okay okay in my
dream I was in my old house back when I
lived out in the woods no cell reception
and no neighbors I was in the shower
washing my hair I think it's so hard to
remember the details I don't remember
the details of Dreams very well but I'll
do my best this part I do remember I
heard this sound like footsteps coming
from the floor above me that quiet
thudding sound coming down through the
ceiling I turned off the water to listen
better and there it was again definitely
footsteps someone was in my house I
threw on my clothes and I slowly snuck
out of the bathroom and I made my way to
the front door I don't know why I just I
just knew I needed to get out of there
just when I opened it I heard the
footsteps behind me and I turned around
and there was this man there huge like
seven feet tall massive Tangled beard
wild eyes and holding an ax we stared at
each other for a long time and he just
smiled like he was so sure he was going
to kill me I have a lovely time doing it
I ran out of the house and into the
woods and I I could hear him coming
after me branches hit me in the face and
cut up my arms as I ran and I just knew
I had to get away but then I started to
get that feeling you get when you run in
dreams like your legs don't work like
you're pushing through water I was
running as fast as I could but I wasn't
going forward at all and then I felt a
hand grabbing my hair yanking my head
back in the blade of the ax slicing
across my cheek he whispered in my ear
and his breath smelled like Rotting
Flesh and I'll never forget this next
part he said we're not done playing yet
I'm gonna take you about a ton of pieces
and save your head for last Dr Robert
gray I was sitting on the couch next to
my wife we were watching television I
turned to ask her a question and she was
staring at me with these dilated pupils
so big her eyes looked all black and
then she opened her mouth to speak to me
I thought I got wider and wired her and
had no teeth just this expanding tunnel
of pink flesh that started to suck me
inside until my head disappeared into
her mouth and I began to suffocate I
haven't been able to look my wife in the
eye all day today other dream journals
were less detailed research assistant
Matt Guero simply wrote my dog ate me
while senior researcher Barbara Bradley
wrote I was stuck inside my fish tank
and my fish were feeding me human flakes
no matter how frightening or absurd the
dream details were all the staff
reported experiencing feelings of
intense stress and panic while having
them and after waking up
scp-080 was contained in the 4 meter by
4 meter room with a small antechamber on
the South Wall providing researchers
with access to the space on the other
side of the north wall there is an
observation room where researchers can
view the containment room through a
window the window is outfitted with thin
blackout curtains which released when
the observation room door has fully
closed no one may attend to remove
scp-080 from its containment at any time
under any circumstances no light sources
may be brought into the room and no more
than one 7 watt incandescent light bulb
may be lit inside additionally no
objects may be brought into the room
that can be used to hide scp-080 in any
way anyone who breaks these rules will
be swiftly and strictly disciplined and
may be subject to termination following
incident080-1 the containment measures
have been re-evaluated and additional
measures have been proposed during this
incident two senior researchers entered
the observation room and released the
blackout curtains certain that this was
a safe way to observe scp-080 without
being influenced by its adverse effects
the two remained in the room for 40
minutes at this point the two fell
asleep it is unknown what exactly
happened after this however after this
incident all staff suffering from
anomalous nightmares reported having
their first full night's sleep since the
research had begun it was as if the
entity's appetite had been temporarily
sated and it had released the rest of
the team from its influence in light of
incident 080-1 a member of the research
team suggested that a d-class be left in
scp-080's room once a month in order to
feed it and protect the rest of the team
from psychological harm after some
debate and opposition from the Ethics
Committee this proposal was approved by
the o5 council now the entity is kept on
a regular feeding schedule and the staff
stream journals have been relatively
uneventful ever since it turns out that
sometimes the price for a good night's
sleep is just a little bit of human
sacrifice who doesn't love a walk
through a dark Forest the site of
branches set against the low Moonlight
looking like all manner of dark and
twisted claws reaching out of the night
to grab at you every step brings with it
the snap of a Broken Twig that
practically Echoes around you whenever a
breeze rustles the leaves on the trees
you feel like something might just be
following you moving through the forest
towards you it is easy to get lost in a
force at night after all that's why the
children's song warns us that if you go
down to the woods today you'd better not
go alone the image of a forest in the
darkness has inspired fear for
Generations from Fireside folk tales
telling of wolves and monsters lurking
among the trees to Modern horror games
about a tall faceless man in a suit
stalking you through the woods and then
of course there's
scp-060 otherwise known as The Infernal
occult skeleton now despite the name as
cp060 is in actual fact a forest or at
least it's a forest to begin with a
picturesque Grove of 17 tall white oak
trees spread out across eight acres of
land in rural Northeast soda it almost
looks like something out of a tourist
brochure a beautiful stretch of forest
sitting under clear skies well during
the daytime anyway if you ever find
yourself hiking through a corner of
Minnesotan Forest that isn't in any of
the guidebooks then tread carefully you
might just stumble upon the demolished
ruins of a house that used to stand
among the trees out in seclusion and a
word of advice to you if you happen
across this place do not under any
circumstances stop walking for a smoke
break of course thanks to the good Folks
at the SCP Foundation you're unlikely to
ever just wander your way into
scp-060 more likely they'll administer
you with amnestics the foundation's
patented memory altering drugs and send
you on your Merry way totally oblivious
to the huge hard to miss greenhouses
containing
scp-060 Beyond those Glass Walls you
might have caught glimpses of foundation
Personnel watering the trees carefully
tending to each
scp-060 specimen maybe you saw them
Gathering up leaves and pruning each
tree individually composting every part
of dead plant matter instead of leaving
the White Oaks to grow freely and
perhaps you even notice that not one
member of personnel was carrying a
lighter on their person nor a taser or
so much as a small box of matches
nothing that can start a fire or rather
you would remember seeing all that if
the omnistics hadn't already made you
forget but what's so special about these
trees why would the SCP Foundation go to
the extent of housing a collection of
White Oaks in greenhouses and
meticulously oversee their growth what
is it about these particular specimens
that make Personnel so cautious about
fire safety and why on Earth is scp-060
a collection of trees referred to by the
nickname The Infernal occult skeleton
well the answer to all those questions
becomes pretty apparent the moment any
of the scp-060 oak trees Catch Fire and
something comes hurtling out of the
forest that something is known as
scp-060 Alpha standing at just over two
meters tall The Entity takes the form of
an adult human skeleton much more than
just a spooky scary collection of Bones
scp-060 Alpha is fully animate capable
of moving of its own accord without the
aid of muscles or a nervous system oh
and it also happens to be on fire move
aside Ghost Rider scp-060 Alpha is in go
from Skull to toe bones in bright white
Flames burning at a temperature of
approximately 1500 degrees Celsius or
almost 3000 degrees Fahrenheit for
reference that's just shy of the melting
point of iron and hot enough to Grant a
human being a quick but agonizingly
painful death granted after a few
seconds of that heat your nerve endings
would be scalded so maybe you wouldn't
feel that much pain but 1500 Celsius is
enough to burn the moisture right out of
your skin melt your eyeballs and
generally fry you to a crisp in a matter
of minutes if not seconds good thing
scp-060 Alpha isn't known for being
highly aggressive and hostile oh wait it
is ah not good upon manifestation the
burning skeleton will attempt to do as
much damage as possible and usually to
whoever is closest it can appear at any
time and after as little as 20 grams
worth of one of the scp-060 trees is
burned as if being actively hostile and
burning hot enough to reshape metal
wasn't bad enough
scp-060 Alpha has also shown itself to
be fiercely intelligent The Entity seems
to retain knowledge whenever it
manifests and has gained a growing
familiarity with the layout of the
foundation site that contains the
scp-060 Oaks The Infernal occult
skeletons methods of attack tend to
include throwing its entire body at
flammable materials however it will
avoid causing any damage to specimens of
scp-060 the skeletal entity can run at
speeds up to 50 miles per hour now
that's almost the same speed as a
gazelle just picturing anything
traveling towards you at that speed is
horrifying let alone something headed
straight for you at gazelle levels of
speed while also on fire it is this
combination of speed and heat that means
scp-060 Alpha poses such a threat to
anyone close whenever it appears if left
unchecked the entity could easily cause
colossal and widespread forest fires and
property damage interestingly any areas
that scp-060 Alpha does burn with its
Flames will start to yield saplings of
the scp-060 Oaks around six weeks after
the fire has stopped the foundation
doesn't allow these saplings to grow to
full size and instead pulls them from
the ground and disposes of them
composting the saplings to feed the
other scp-060 specimens luckily the
biggest strength of scp-060 alpha its
Flames also happens to be its greatest
weakness it is possible to fight the
fires of the infernal occult skeleton by
dousing it with water or any other
materials capable of dowsing flames
whether it's sand or foam from a fire
extinguisher of course this is a lot
hotter and harder to put out than any
ordinary smaller scale fire but despite
being a difficult task it is not
impossible about 500 liters of water
should do the trick if you've got a big
enough bucket nearby after that scp-060
Alpha will be weakened gradually
collapsing and turning into dust however
if another part of an scp-0603 is burned
and the entity reappears It is believed
that this will be the same infernal
occult skeleton rather than a new
version of the bone burning being so we
have a Grove of oak trees that manifest
a flaming skeleton if they are ever
burned maybe that's not the weirdest
thing you'd see in a Minnesotan Forest
but wait there's something thing else
cast your mind back a few minutes and
you'll remember that we mentioned some
ruins the remains of a demolished house
that used to stand secluded among the
scp-060 white oak trees knowing that the
infernal occult skeleton can appear from
The Oaks might make it obvious what
happened to this house but there's still
a story to be told here The house's
owner was a man by the name of Jonathan
corehill now Jonathan was something of
an odd man considered a bit of an
eccentric Tucson he preferred to spend
his time in solitude alone with his own
thoughts for company rather than
mingling among the rest of the world
even his own family noticed that Mr
corehill was drifting away from them
becoming a more bitter nihilistic person
in his old age and choosing isolation
over human connection now sure
loneliness doesn't hold much appeal to
everyone but sometimes there are people
who just prefer being alone that might
be what Drew Jonathan corehill to a
secluded Little House in the forests of
Minnesota somewhere no one would bother
him for the most part the rest of the
corehill family adjusted to their
eccentric relatives Behavior Jonathan
would have rarely accepted visitors to
his house in the forest but he still
kept in contact with those who he'd been
close with most notably he'd regularly
share phone calls with his brother one
Christopher corehill that is until
something seemed to change unexpectedly
in the year 1996 on one of their calls
Jonathan outright told Christopher to
never contact him again severing any
ties with any remaining family members
and friends in the outside world
Jonathan cut everyone off living within
his own bubble where he could immerse
himself in his unusual interests
according to Christopher his brother had
seemed otherwise normal up until a
certain phone conversation but Jonathan
had become obsessed with the occult
specifically he had embroiled himself in
the history of the Victorian era and
certain Supernatural practices that had
been undertaken in that time period now
whether Christopher for honored his
brother's wish to sever ties is unknown
a mail carrier would visit Jonathan's
home in the woods not long after their
phone call maybe among the envelopes
this Courier was delivering what could
have been a letter from Christopher or
other members of the corehill family
begging they're a strange relative to
come back to the world you see even
people who claim to prefer being on
their own sometimes need human
interaction talking to people and being
in the presence of friends and family
are hugely important factors in
maintaining a positive state of mental
health but what happens when someone
rejects that entirely and instead
becomes lost in their obsessive study of
the occult while the mail carrier was
the first to find out arriving at
Jonathan corehill's Woodland house The
Courier found the place looking almost
skeletal a shell of the building that
had once stood in the forest according
to the locals the carrier had been sent
to deliver a notice to Mr corehill
explaining that his house was being
foreclosed but it seems some
or something had beaten them to it a
fire had spread from The house's
fireplace quickly engulfing the entire
structure presumably with Jonathan still
inside it wasn't until later that very
same year that Jonathan corehill was
officially reported as a missing person
case with the local authorities any
search that was undertaken in an attempt
to find him uncovered next to no
evidence of his whereabouts to this day
nobody knows for certain if Jonathan
corehill is dead or alive his
whereabouts are unknown on the surface
it might be easy to make the assumption
that the infernal occult skeleton
reduced the reclusive old man to nothing
more than a cinder it definitely seems
plausible that Jonathan collecting
firewood to keep himself warm in his
isolation accidentally chopped down part
of an scp-060 oak put it in his
fireplace and called forth the vengeful
flaming bones but perhaps we shouldn't
be so certain after all corehill's house
wasn't entirely burned down despite the
entity normally trying to cause as much
damage as possible whenever it appears
and on top of that no human remains were
found in the house and the skeleton of
scp-060 alpha had to have come from
somewhere right
scp-060 offers a few warnings and not
just about the dangers of traveling
through the forest alone the appearance
of the Flaming skeleton whenever the
scp-060 White Oaks are burned could
serve as a reminder that we need to be
Village in protecting the forests of
this world trees are one of our few
sustainable resources but for every one
we cut down or that catches fire it
takes years to regrow a replacement and
perhaps the third and final warning of
the infernal occult skeleton is simply
don't play with matches especially
around trees otherwise you might get
burned imagine if you could predict the
future not perfectly mind you but with
enough accuracy that brilliant enough
Minds say the best and brightest of the
SCP Foundation could plausibly reverse
engineer the main determinative factors
that caused a certain timeline to form
imagine if through carefully studying
these determinative factors the
foundation could carefully shape the
future into one that's more favorable
for the human race than all the
Alternatives the preferred option if you
will would this not be advantageous your
next question is a very natural one
given the circumstances how does one
predict the future in such a manner well
the answer is uncomplicated but that
doesn't by any means make it easy you go
there spend a few months looking around
and then come back to report your
findings that's right folks we're not
talking psychics and seers here prepare
to expand your mind and please don't
worry if it all gets a little timey
whimy because
scp-2003 is the SCP foundation's self
made time machine even most of the staff
at the SCP Foundation itself don't know
much about scp-2003 given the highly
sensitive nature of the projects
surrounding it much like scp-2000 is a
trump card securing our present in the
case of a catastrophic XK Class end of
the world scenario
scp-2003 is our prophylactic for such a
thing happening in the foreseeable
future what's far more unique about
scp-2003 is that the SCP Foundation
created this Ace in the Hole from
scratch the scp-2003 time machine was
invented over a 25-year period by
reverse engineering the anomalous
technology of three different classified
anomalies and retrofitting them into our
own non-anomalous framework the massive
machine is housed in armed site-47 a
remote and well-guarded facility
disguised as an oil refinery while
extensive records of scp-2003's
construction have been made by the
foundation and it stands to reason that
the machine could be reliably and
successfully reproduced in a different
context even the most intelligent
scientists taking part in the project
couldn't explain how or why it actually
operates in the words of another mad
inventor it just works the operating
principle of scp-2003 are relatively
simple to understand it is able to break
the laws of the space-time Continuum by
immediately transporting anything or
anyone placed in its Central chamber to
some point in the chronological future
the subjects transported forwards will
remain in this future for several months
before instantaneously being transported
back to the exact location they were
standing in the future in order to
prevent some kind of unfortunate
accident like phasing back halfway
through a wall and becoming unpleasant
Modern Art the foundation has
established a secure facility for
travelers to head and wait out the rest
of their time when their mission is
complete through extensive testing
including that which was performed under
the review of Project X and Shepard the
foundation has discovered a great deal
about the nature of time travel via
scp-2003 we'll outline the most crucial
caveats here so what happens next makes
a lot more sense to you after all if
time travel was easy everyone would do
it first as we alluded to earlier the
data collected by scp-2003 on the nature
of the future is often unclear imprecise
and unreliable for example the data
collected from 2003 did provide
extremely useful in predicting and
preventing a massive security breach
over at site 19 in 1997. so naturally
when it predicted a devastating series
of earthquakes off the west coast of the
United States in 1999 an event that
several agents sent through scp-2003
observed directly it came as a shock to
everyone when nothing happened the
foundation discovered following this
that all Productions needed to be
contextualized through heaps of metadata
for it to be of any real use in
predicting or preventing our specific
future the foundation also discovered
that certain individuals had a strangely
disproportionate effect on the unfolding
of future events let's say for example
scp-2003 discovers that a new type of
nuclear weapon will be invented in 2028
and quickly adopted by a number of
leading Nations by 2030 and by 2035
tensions will rise Sabers will Rattle
and this nuclear weapon will be used on
mass to destroy human society as we know
it naturally in order to prevent this
the foundation might see to it that
certain groups of nuclear scientists
certain generals and certain world
leaders get liquidated and yet another
trip into the future shows that this
massive nuclear war was not averted but
why because it just so happens that this
event was inexplicably tied to the birth
of a little boy named James Hoskins in
Saskatoon Circa 2025 despite little
Jimmy Hoskins seemingly having nothing
to do with the actual development of the
technology seeing as he's only 10 years
old when the bombs start falling the
foundation scientists working under
Project X and Shepherd keep a database
of all these highly determinative
individuals also known as magnifier
individuals so they can keep tabs on how
they're affecting any future timelines
speaking of future timelines we're
afraid to tell you that this penultimate
caveat isn't exactly a pleasant one
there are few to any cohesive future
timelines where Humanity survives long
term bummer right the foundation calls
these loose timelines determinative sets
and in the majority of them human
civilization collapses all humans die
and in some cases the Earth becomes
completely uninhabitable to all forms of
life the foundation is currently seeking
a more optimistic option through
controlled manipulations of the Casual
stream in our time but currently all we
have is the preferred option option xn
and if you're someone one who would jump
at the chance to travel into the future
and take a gander at all the wondrous or
terrifying sites there's actually one
pretty major caveat of scp-2003 that
we've been playing rather close to the
chest early Foundation tests found out
that the time travel process via
scp-2003 is extremely damaging to plant
and animal tissue rather than just going
on a wacky time travel Adventure like
Doctor Who or Austin Powers it'd be a
little more like stepping into a giant
microwave while dressed in a spacesuit
made of aluminum foil you're gonna die a
horrible death but there is one silver
lining well maybe not silver from your
perspective probably more like pewter
the foundation has discovered a way to
viably send human adjacent subjects
through time with scp-2003 without
instantaneous death we just can't
promise that you're going to like it you
see the one kind of organic tissue that
seems to survive the scp-2003 time
travel process is the human brain and
nervous system
due to the highly controlled nature of
project xn Shepard the foundation can't
just send in d-classes to do the job
they instead use actual agents though
mostly ones who are nearing or Beyond
retirement or are suffering from a
terminal illness these agents are dosed
on a course of anti-anxiety
antidepressant and antipsychotic
chemotherapy to toughen their minds for
the horrors to come though the exact
nature of these Horrors is kept secret
from them until it's already happened
you may be familiar with one of the
foundation's most well-known front
companies Boston Dynamics as well as one
of their most famous products the
robotic quadrupedal probe known as Big
Dog well in order to send a sentient
being through time without them being
completely destroyed by a CP 2003 the
agent's brain and nervous system are
entirely removed from their body and
transported into the body of a modified
big dog still think it'd be fun to time
travel hey don't look so nervous for
everyone who agrees to be part of an
scp-2000 3 mission and survives you'll
get one hell of a pension or at least
your family will if that's any
consolation now that you understand all
this let's come clean about this
mysterious Project X and Shepherd we've
been alluding to throughout the video it
all started with a letter to the heads
of the scp-2003 research project from
05-7 a member of the legendary o5
Council that instructs the foundation in
all that it does the letter read up
until this point all attempts at Future
intervention using scp-2003 have been
Limited in scope and Scatter shot in
nature I've seen the wisdom in this
approach it is informed by painstaking
contingency planning and risk benefit
evaluation the past 18 months of reports
however have promise if you are bold
enough to seize the initiative we may
have found a way out here the price so
there's always a surprise as you fell
know consider this note an official
change in policy as of today all efforts
at interview attention are now aimed at
bringing about and preserving xn
designated magnify individuals
associated with xn are to be protected
from undue interference at the expense
of all other priorities in particular
neurodian must be allowed to die in the
manner most observations have predicted
for her if anything at all changes in
that regard make it happen I trust that
you're familiar enough is the rest of
the determinative sets to understand why
we're going this way so in short of all
the potential timelines o5-7 once the
researchers assigned to scp-2003 to
ensure that the timeline xn is the one
that actually comes to be seeing as it's
preferable to the Alternatives hence
Project X and Shepard you're probably
wondering what happens in Timeline xn
that makes it the most desirable outcome
possible well things continue as normal
everything from anomalous activity to
social unrest to environmental factors
stay pretty much the same as time time
goes on until 2349 when a giant 22
kilometer asteroid strikes the Earth and
wipes out the majority of humanity in an
instant following this the world becomes
unfit for human habitation hey don't
look so glum you all be dead by then
well except Dr bright sorry again jack
we at least get a nice three centuries
before we're wiped from the cosmic table
your next question is probably if the
preferred option has Humanity being
wiped out by a giant asteroid in a
little over 300 years what are all the
other ones aren't we entitled to a
multiple choice future if we don't feel
comfortable with being completely
annihilated by an asteroid before we're
even halfway to the year 3000 well we'll
give you a little tasting platter of
potential timelines and you can take
your pick there was the narrowly avoided
scenario XB where things progressed in a
similar fashion to scenario xn except a
massive gamma ray burst from the Sun in
April 2017 wiped out all life on Earth
within 38 seconds then their scenario
taxi where the birth of an unnamed boy
in Turkmenistan combined with the
election of Sir William Entwistle as
prime minister of New Zealand in 2049
leads to a world destroying nuclear
exchange between Israel and greater
Indonesia in 2058 and he attempts to
stop it just make it happen sooner or
what about scenario X age here A Deadly
mutated form of influenza causes the
deaths of over a billion people
worldwide combating this threat causes
increased cooperation between World
governments that actually resulted in a
huge net Improvement for Global Peace
and quality of life it seems unrealistic
we know but scp-2003 doesn't lie however
despite things going well all known life
on Earth just vanishes on July 29 2059.
it's a hell of an unpleasant twist after
things start going so well for once in
scenario XO the anomalous increases in
frequency and magnitude in 2037 this
leads to a broken masquerade scenario
where the foundation's web of secrecy
collapses and anomalous chaos Reigns
across the globe the foundation's
members are hunted and killed and World
governments attempting to weaponize the
anomalous leads to a new arms race that
wipes out all of humanity by 2048 or
maybe scenario XU is more your cup of
tea in this one the sun collapses
leading to Eternal darkness and massive
temperature drops inexplicably humans
still survive but are in a state of
constant unmoving Agony and maybe if you
just really love spiders you'll get a
kick out of scenario XX where a
mysterious pathogenic protist causes the
majority of humanity to fall in love
with the Brazilian wandering spider one
of the few spiders that pose an actual
threat to humans the diverting of all
resources meant to keep humans alive to
instead breeding the spiders combined
with many many many many many people
being killed by the resulting spiders
leads to 6 billion deaths in the early
2030s but hey you'll get to see some
pretty great spiders if that's your
thing I guess scenario X n is hardly a
picnic nobody likes the idea of facing
an Armageddon straight out of Armageddon
when that asteroid kills all life on
Earth in 300 years but while it
undeniably isn't perfect it may just be
the best option we've got ah isn't the
future amazing are you afraid of haunted
houses what about haunted castles or
prisons or mental asylums we've all seen
or heard Tales of terrible tortured
Souls walking down long and lonely
hallways looking for people to pass
their ancient pain onto but what about
something a lot more subtle perhaps as
humble and unassuming as a cozy little
Woodshed an adventurer named Kate would
find that sometimes Terrible Things hide
in simple places with every step Twigs
broke under the sole of her boot their
snaps echoing Around The Emptiness of
the surrounding Forest Birds caught down
at her from their perches up above a
grave Omen a warning not to tread
further well at least to anyone who
actually bought into all that
superstitious stuff cat was far from a
believer in that sort of thing although
at the same time she had more than a
passing interest in all things occult
and unnatural for her it was less about
the actual practice of certain things
the appeal was more about the stories
that those practices inspired Legends
and myths spooky Tales of ghosts or the
Dead Rising from their graves and of
course the magical mother of them all
witchcraft although her fascination with
the inexplicable and Macabre rarely if
ever overlapped with her other big
passion hiking until of course today she
could Trek anywhere and wanted to aim
for everywhere through sprawling
national parks filled with vibrant
Greenery up the sides of mountains
climbing up to the Peaks to across
deserts following the almost empty
highways to get from one tiny World town
to the next there was something about
getting to not just know about the world
but to actively go and see it with her
own two eyes to actually be out there in
it that felt so right on her current
Journey Kate had taken herself on a Long
Trail through the heart of the American
Midwest bugging a heavy pack over her
shoulders filled with her tense sleeping
bag outdoor cooking supplies and all
manner of camping gear she had set off
following the winding path of the Patoka
river which ran around or adjacent to a
few of the major cities in the state of
Indiana Kate was hoping to follow the
flow of its main body of water all the
way through to the city of Jasper from
there it would be a straight shot over
to the similarly named Patoka Lake and
after she had walked around the entire
circumference of that it would be a long
hike East towards West Virginia home of
the Blue Ridge Mountains sir it was one
hell of an ambitious trip for one person
traveling alone but Kate liked to keep
her Journeys unencumbered having someone
else coming with her would just slow her
down or they wouldn't be able to keep up
with her at all there's no fun at all in
that stopping for the night Kate lit
herself a campfire she had to make sure
to keep it far enough from the trees to
avoid starting any potential
catastrophes but also not too close to
the wet Bank of the Patoka otherwise her
kindling wouldn't catch a light there
were so many variables to consider for
any aspiring camper Sparks from the
Flint that she always took on her
travels struck the dry twig she had
collected and soon a gentle orange glow
and wave of low heat were radiating from
it the fire provided Kate with just
enough light to unfold and Peg down her
tent as the diminishing visibility of
the dusk gave way to the encroaching
nighttime darkness before getting
comfortable in her sleeping bag she put
out her campfire using water from the
Patoka then zipped up the front of her
tent keeping a flimsy cloth barrier
between herself and the local Wildlife
not everyone found it easy to sleep in
the woods as Kate did she couldn't
remember a time when the noise of raking
Twigs or the sounds of movement outside
had ever kept her awake even now the
rustle of leaves and branches did little
to disturb her regardless of whether it
was just the wind or something else
moving through the bushes woken up by
the sun rising its warm Light breaking
through the trees Kate readied herself
to leave she never stopped at the same
place for more than one night and rarely
slept for any longer than she needed to
a nice eight-hour recharge of her energy
reserves and then it was back to the
open road after a quick breakfast she
packed up her single person campsite
folded up her tent and stuffed it back
into her bag Kate had been just about to
leave when she noticed something was
missing her Compass it had been in her
backpack which she kept in the tent with
her all night quickly scanning the
ground around her she couldn't see it
weird but she figured she had obviously
dropped it at some point during her hike
and would have to pick up a new one when
she got to Jasper it didn't matter she
could just follow the Patoka River as
planned although it didn't quite sit
easy with her the rest of the day's Trek
she'd packed the compass that she was
absolutely certain of after all she knew
it wasn't like her to leave it behind
but then again had she could she have
forgotten it entirely over the next few
hours the question went round and round
in Kate's head as she walked along the
bank of the river silently starting to
doubt herself she drifted a little
deeper into the woods until out of the
corner of her eye she spotted something
standing among the trees it wasn't an
animal or even a figure but a structure
spending so much time out in nature
anything man-made usually stuck out as
an obvious unignorable eyesore to Kate
she looked at it from a distance it
looked like an old house isolated out in
the woods a short walk from the Patoka
River checking the sky over her shoulder
Kate noticed it was getting late again
the daylight having gradually lowered
while she had been wondering about why
she had left her Compass behind or if it
had been taken deciding to set up camp
closer to the little house she turned
and headed in to inspect it closer the
place was far from the lap of modern
luxury not that Kate couldn't live
without running water or electricity for
long stints of time but it wasn't a
house that had been built recently
although she was no expert in either
archeology or architecture Kate didn't
think anyone had lived there for decades
possibly even centuries it was almost
medieval a single room that was
completely ramshackle practically
falling apart at the seams everywhere
she looked the wood that had originally
been used to build it was either rotting
away or had been broken into splintered
remains plants from the forest had
started growing through the floors and
the walls as if nature was trying to
reclaim this spot of land where someone
had once come to get away from the rest
of the world sign cat shook her head as
she looked at the dilapidated house
there was no way even she could sleep
there it was too much of a safety risk
parts of the ceiling could easily fall
on her during the night if the wind
picked up enough turning to leave she
stopped in her tracks as she noticed
another structure much smaller behind
the house it had been so dwarfed in size
by the slightly bigger building that it
was completely obscured from view but it
looked to be in much better shape in
terms of its structural Integrity it was
a Woodshed its front door hanging lazily
open while not exactly Brand New by
anyone's standards it was at least far
more intact than the main house taking a
few steps forward Kate felt something
like glass crunch under the heel of her
boot she scanned the floor instinctively
checking for any more so as to not
injure herself even with the low amount
of sunlight fading ever rapidly it
didn't look like more kicking her boat
to loosen The Shard she made her way
towards the Woodshed not noticing that
what she'd been standing on had been a
compass reaching the shed she peered
inside it was Pitch Black within almost
as dark as the rest of the force would
be in the few minutes taking off her
backpack and setting it down she
searched inside for her flashlight
retrieving it and flipping on the switch
she looked back into the shed and that
was when she saw it taking a step back
cat tripped over her bag scrambling back
up to her feet to make sure she had seen
what she thought she had it was just
lying there still and lifeless for a
split second she hoped it was a trick of
the light just an old decaying bump of
wood but it wasn't it was a body the
remains were charred reduced to little
more than bones some time ago even the
ground next to it looked like it had
been scorched blackened by some intense
fire damage Kate's eyes were so
transfixed on the burned massive bones
but a sudden sound startled her Thunder
growled above immediately telling her
she had little choice in what to do next
her options were either she could sleep
outdoors and get drenched by the rain
and possibly catch hypothermia from
being cold and wet or she could spend a
night in the cramped confines of this
woodshed which you would have to share
with a long dead body walking back
outside to retrieve her bag she pulled
out a ground sheet and used it to cover
up the bones it was a mostly sleepless
night and those were a rarity for Kate
any sleep she did get was light easily
interrupted by as little as her own
movements and offered her no actual rest
but for the next few hours she just lay
awake on the wooden floor it wasn't the
sounds of rain drumming against the shed
ceiling or the booming of thunderclaps
that were keeping her awake thoughts of
what she was going to do about the bones
kept coming to the Forefront of Kate's
mind should she report it to the police
when she got to Jasper was there even
any point if she had no idea where on
the map this abandoned place was
frustrated she tossed and turned
eventually sitting up as something made
a sound it was a low creaking rusty
metal hinge screeching for a lack of any
oiling over the years the door was open
swinging lazily in the decreasing winds
its lock having long since broken
rumbling to herself Kate reach for an
old shovel that had been left in the
shed and went to grab the open door as
her head poked out from the shed she
looked around it was the middle of the
night nothing to be seen anywhere around
yet she couldn't escape the feeling she
was being watched taking the shovel she
damned it underneath the door frame
keeping it closed a blast that was quiet
maybe now she'd be able to get some much
needed sleep and she did but that's when
the nightmare started the dream was
bizarre unlike anything Kate had ever
experienced before she instantly
recognized the warm flickering orange
glow of a large fire before her
naturally she started to Pace her way
towards it the fire's heat washing over
her the closer she got but as she
approached Kate noticed something moving
amongst the Flames arms flailed trying
desperately to extinguish the blaze legs
kicking and writhing and that was on top
of the screaming another figure was
standing facing the bonfire their back
to Cade as she walked closer still with
every step the sounds of insects buzzing
could be heard getting louder and louder
but it wasn't until she stepped near
enough that she saw where the noise was
coming from a swarm of bugs was darting
through the air hovering around the
other figure there were enough of the
insects that they formed would look like
a cloak every part of it moving and
buzzing of its own accord the whole
nightmare was so vivid Kate had no idea
if it had been brought on by her
exhaustion or that her mind was still
fixated on the bone she'd found in the
Woodshed dehydration lack of food or
even some other influence it could have
been any one of those factors that had
caused her to dream a dream like this or
a combination of all of them nonetheless
she could feel the bugs tapping at her
skin as she walked up to the other
figure still unable to see them clearly
the noise of insect Wings whizzed past
her ears louder than ever loud enough to
be real putting a hand on the figure's
shoulder Kate to turn them around it was
a woman
or what was left of her she had huge
gaping wounds left by something that had
been cruelly buried in her face yet
somehow she was still standing dead but
also alive at the same time the swarm of
bugs around her moved with her body as
she turned and faced Kate a pair of
glassy eyes staring at her they were
both blank completely empty each one
missing its pupil opening her mouth the
woman let out a piercing blood curdling
shriek all around her the sound of the
bugs got louder almost deafening and as
she screamed so did Kate panting and
shuddering she bolted upright shock
racking her entire body hard-sutting
against her rib cage instantly the exact
moment she woke up Kate realized that
feeling was back she had spent so much
of her time hiking through the woods on
her own that she could tell when someone
was watching her in the dark she fumbled
for her flashlight and clicked it on to
reveal the door was still jammed shut
apart from her there was no one else in
inside the shed No One Alive at least
looking over her shoulder she could see
the bones behind her and immediately
backed away from them as far she could
in that tiny wooden Hut she had covered
them before going to bed she was certain
of it hadn't she all of a sudden Kate
felt her skin start to itch an intense
irritating feeling she had experienced
the effects of poison ivy and all sorts
of plants that caused similar reactions
but this was easily a thousand times
worse her skin felt like it was burning
she scraped her fingernails down her
exposed arm trying to suppress the
itching even for a moment but it did
nothing she scratched at the other arm
over and over again in one spot until
her flesh was pink and raw still no
change Kate raked her nails over her own
body this time leaving a deep scratch
trailing over her arm under the light of
her torch she'd realized that she'd
drawn blood she looked back at the bones
in The Scorch corner of the shed the
skull was facing straight towards her
hollowed out eye socket staring as empty
as the pupilous eyes of the woman in her
nightmare it had done this it must have
done she thought reaching towards the
door dropping her flashlight she
wrenched the shovel out from where she
used it to wedge the entrance closed she
stood up kicking her sleeping bag and
backpack to the side as hard as she
could desperate to make the itching stop
Kate brought the shovel downwards the
head of it snapped the already weakened
floorboards of the shed exposing the
soft dry Earth beneath maybe if she
buried those charred remains whatever
was happening to her would stop
frantically she started digging hurling
shovelfuls of dirt through the shed door
enlisted further open creaking loudly on
its rusted hinges again causing Kate to
turn startled at the sound of it
Knocking against the outer wall of the
shed someone was looking right at her
she could feel it as real and as
persistent as the itching feeling I
crawled over her skin like the tiny legs
of an army of insects she dug further
eventually throwing the shovel to one
side and dragging her hand through the
exposed earth below desperately
burrowing through and only stopping to
use any Rock she found to try and stop
the itch all she achieved was drawing
more blood her fingers touched something
soft but solid and Kate rushed away to
clear more of the excess dirt trying to
uncover whatever it was it felt like a
long Mass just beneath the ground with a
second similar object parallel to it but
the further along with it she reached
the quicker she realized what it was a
lank clearing more of the dirt higher up
Kate could feel more a stomach ribs
shoulders and a head reaching for her
flashlight buried under some of the dirt
that had been dug up she pointed it at
the things she'd found the woman the
same one from her nightmare something
inside her chest moved scratching
sharply causing Kate to cough and once
she started she couldn't stop it was
like the itching she'd felt on the
outside had now worked its way inside
and it was spreading no moving in fact
not just moving but crawling through her
lungs burrowing down into her stomach
and at the same time upwards the clawing
of tiny legs digging their way up her
windpipe blocking it Kate couldn't
breathe she dropped to her knees
wretching as she struggled for air
sputtering as she felt something move at
the back of her throat that was when she
heard the buzzing again locusts a swarm
of them came spilling out of Kate's
mouth she couldn't scream let alone
catch her breath they filled the shed in
seconds engulfing her entire body as
more and more of the desert bugs still
came pouring from her mouth outside the
wind kicked up again with enough Force
to blow the door to the Woodshed closed
dropping Kate inside with the bugs that
tore at her there was a single word on
the wooden surface of the door written
in deep black charcoal she'd missed it
the door had been open when she found
the shed the word was which the SCP
Foundation would later find this cursed
cabin and would naturally lose a number
of d-classes to a horrific form of
locust-based Suffocation while there are
Clues as to what exactly is going on in
this terrible place from the malice of a
long dead sorceress to the lingering
revenge of a woman wrongfully persecuted
definite answers as to the anomalous
mechanisms of the shed known as
scp-4595 still allude even the
foundation's finest Minds it's a place
so mysterious and dangerous that the
special containment procedures read for
safety purposes no Personnel are
permitted to enter
scp-4595
scp-4595 should only be entered by
authorized testing Personnel under the
supervision of the scp-4595 research
lead under no circumstances is
scp-4595-a to be disturbed in any way so
perhaps we'll never truly know why a
humble wooden shed in Jasper Indiana
causes such horrifying effects for its
victims the SCP Foundation thinks it's
safer to just lock it away and forget
about it letting its ancient wood and
old bones rot in the dark but if you are
really curious about the truth you can
always take a walk down the side of the
Patoka River and pay the witch a visit
if you're lucky you might even get to
leave
stop right up folks we've got all kinds
of refreshing and tasty treats here for
you today popcorn peanuts cotton candy
and even fried dough yesterday here at
SCP explained we're offering the top of
the line anomalous delectable foodstuffs
for all your circus themed fun time
occasions and that's because today yes
today on this YouTube platform our
Infamous acronym doesn't stand for
secure contain protect it stands for
sweet confectionery products and let me
tell you dear viewer the SCP we're
looking at today just might be the most
decadent durable and dangerous dessert
that's ever desired to be devoured we're
talking about
scp-3077 or as they are better known the
sugar Golems these little fellas are
safe class and also totally harmless so
long as you take the proper precautions
what's the matter don't you believe me
don't you think it's nice of us to cover
a safe SCP now and again and hey now why
all this dull talk about rules and
regulations in the first place you don't
go out to the carnival to not take wild
and exciting risks every spinny twirly
and whirly ride on the fairgrounds comes
with a statistically higher chance of a
tragic mishap the following you and any
other Thrill Seekers around you but we
all take that chance anyway for the
extraordinary Rush of the experience and
such is the wacky and wonderful ways of
our adorable and questionably edible
Chums the sugar Golems don't you just
love them folks ain't they a sight for
sore eyes and are paying for sweet teeth
well we're only just getting started The
Best Is Yet To Come ladies and not
ladies so pull up a chair and be sure to
watch what we've got in store you can
make like a piece of old candy and stick
around now that's a nice laughing
back relax and make sure to enjoy the
show you should also subscribe to SCP
explained if you'd like to continue to
be entertained hey that rhyme what do
you know I'm about and I didn't even
know it I'll draw while scp-3077 refers
to the anomalous substance contained in
site 81. the semi-humanoid instances
which are nicknamed sugar Golems are
themselves inanimate and independent
byproduct that naturally spawns from
scp-3077 when it is allowed to exist
outside of containment procedures the
most important of these containment
procedures being that scp-3077 must
remain at a constant temperature of well
below its freezing point and only be
stored in containers fall to capacity
less its aforementioned byproducts
attempt to breach containment the total
volume of scp-3077 within the cryogenic
containment unit equals almost 2200
liters and it is believed to be the only
known quantity of the anomalous
substance in existence for the sake of
clarity in distinguishing between
scp-3077 and its buy products we'll be
referring to the main object contained
by the foundation as scp-3077 while the
gooey little guys who we know to
spontaneously split off from the source
of scp-3077 will be regarded as
scp-3077-1 as mentioned before
scp-3077-1 instances have been
affectionately dubbed these sugar Golems
every instance of scp-3077-1 resembles
an approximately one meter tall gaunt
humanoid composed of a pure sugar
derived substance commonly known as Rico
and that's Molasses for all y'all
Cowboys over there in the US of a if
you've ever played the classic board
game Candyland you'll have some idea of
what an individual instance of scp-1377
looks like from the Beloved and often
remembered character of Gloppy who lives
in the Molasses swamp section of the
board and is also fittingly made out of
molasses himself yes indeed Gloppy is
truly a delight for a witty Candyland
player to meet what did you say are you
folks too young to know about Candyland
well that factoid certainly makes this
narrator feel pretty old then again I am
taking on the mannerisms and attire of
an old-fashioned Carnival marker so I
suppose a bit of Novel Antiquity comes
with the territory regardless the Golems
are each composed of roughly seven
liters of sweet syrupy goodness and very
much like everyone's favorite character
Gloppy they all like to find lower
bodies and can all emote through crude
yet oddly endearing vocalizations in the
place of intelligible speech while their
facial features are simplistic and
misshapen the Contours of concave eyes
and gaping mouth are usually present the
exact number of these eyes and mouths is
subject to variation much like the color
of the board spaces in a wonderful
wholesome family game of Candyland while
hscp 3077-1 instance is around the same
size the body proportions and overall
shape of each instance are rather fluid
pan fully intended some less oversized
arms or bulbous heads While others might
be conjoined to an adjacent sugar Golem
as if to show that the two are
inseparable as a pair of best buddies or
as some others might put it a couple of
BFFs best friends for fancy frolicking
they really are quite friendly looking
aren't they and aren't they they sure
are but the only thing that these sugary
sweet SCP instances want is to be in the
company of human beings just like you
yes you who else would I be talking to
it's a hard life for this one down
Connie let me tell you these little
sugar Golems love what they do and do
what they love but that doesn't mean
that it's time for Fun and Games even
though
scp-3077-1 instances want to hang around
human beings they don't tend to stop at
hey and hello or whatever those
appropriate greetings sound like when
they are being gurgled by a diminutive
molten sugar monster things can get out
of hand real fast just like an orange
cream popsicle melting in the sound of a
late Summer's Day now listen up it's
important that you pay attention to what
I say next I'm about to book learn you
about what to do with an instance of
scp-3077-1 enters your personal space
the results of prolonged contact with
this SCP can end badly if you're not
careful I'm not going to sugarcoat any
of the chewy details of your Grizzly
fate and I promise that it won't be a
cakewalk so don't be a nerd and listen
up yes that's right I called you a nerd
you know like nerds the candy how do you
folks seriously not know nerds they're a
classic Halloween candy from the Wonka
company and they were very popular back
in the day oh was that you say how long
ago was it back in the day for me that's
a bit of a rude question wouldn't you
say
won't you go ahead and knock it off with
the Wise Guy questions what are you a
pack of Smarties I said Smarties get it
just like that ah never mind let's just
move on to the explanation of how to
survive a close encounter with this SCP
that was the main reason you came all
this way to this here educational and
entertaining video presentation after
all to pick up where I left off
instances of
scp-3077-1 have a tendency to seek out
nearby human life the reason for doing
so is surprisingly simple and alarmingly
well alarming these sticky saccharine
simulacra are solely set on slithering
into people's mouths for the purposes of
gaining total control of their bodies
Yes you heard that right believe it or
not the same anomalous property which
animates the sugar Golem's trickle
bodies is apparently capable of
overriding the human nervous system from
the inside and that's no joke folks
while these tasty treats might sound
sweet to eat you'll be a puppet of meat
from your head to your feet if you don't
complete the tasks I entreat if an
instance of scp-3077-1 attempts to enter
your mouth you you must remember first
and foremost to keep your trap shut
blocking it with a mask or a similar
article of clothing if need be next you
must use your limbs and all available
implements to better the attacking Golem
away while you do your best to keep a
distance of at least Arms Reach between
yourself and the instance it should come
as a relief to our rational people that
scp-1377-1 instances are severely
limited in their physical capabilities
and an adult human of average fitness
can easily hold one off if they know
what to expect the tricky part comes
from the amorphous properties of the
instances of viscous prequel bodies as
well as their anomalous ability to
regenerate from any physical trauma the
only way to permanently destroy an
instance of
scp-3077-1 is to expose it to
temperatures above its melting point
which for you sticklers out there is
approximately 176 degrees Celsius the
most effective weapons against
scp-3077-1 in instances include firearms
flamethrowers and your run-of-the-mill
convection ovens if it is at all
possible to contain the instance within
a sealed vessel such as a large
Tupperware or wooden barrel then you
ought to do whatever you can to prevent
the candy creeps from running amok while
ordinary below zero temperatures are
unable to destroy the anomalous three
call of scp-3077 instances of
scp-30707-1 can effectively be slowed
down or stopped completely if you put
them on Ice whether it's the hot foot or
the cold shoulder some form of extreme
temperature should always be weaponized
when defending oneself from an
scp-1377-1 instance any attempt to crush
or smash an scp-3077-1 instance will
only result in the bad Bonbon breaking
apart and reforming into several more
belligerent bite-sized blighters a human
Under Siege by the sugar Golems might
find themselves quickly outnumbered if
they foolishly attempt to use a melee
weapon against the anomaly ways
basically it's like a more delicious
version of the popular arcade video game
asteroids no I guess that reference was
from before even night time at any rate
instances of scp-3077-1 are difficult to
destroy without access to heat or
freezing the tendency of the Molasses
Menace is to increase in number is made
even worse because of the fact that any
amount of scp-3077 outside of
containment can generate a nearly
infinite number of
scp-3077-1 while even an army of
scp-3077-1 instances is far weaker than
an equivalent pack of hunting animals
the ability to continuously multiply and
Physiology that doesn't experience the
consequences of fatigue means that given
enough time these sugar Golems can
Outlast any amount of human resistance
until they roll over their preferred
prey like a slow insurmountable syrupy
tsunami of surrender seriously scary
stuff some would say but what happens
next is the real kicker folks mindless
ballyhoo's summer Spiel if an instance
of scp-1377-1 manages to Against All
Odds clamor its way into a human
Chatterbox and hijack the poor Sap's
nervous system the victim is immediately
classified as
scp-3077-2
scp-3077-2 instances are easily
distinguished from unaffected humans on
site alone dark tendrils of scp-1377 can
be seen visibly moving beneath the skin
and often emerge from the mouth to
crisscross the instance's face like
makeup the world's most disturbing
circus Cloud that's not all after the
tragic trickly transformation takes
place the movements exhibited by the
instance of
scp-3077-2 will become crooked and Jerky
like a marionette puppeteered by a
frustrated chimpanzee during this time
the instance remains fully conscious
retaining whatever cognitive faculties
it has possessed previous to its
classification but it is unable to
attempt speech or exert autonomy over
its own actions this fun fact was
discovered by studying the EEG
recordings of several
scp-3077-2 instances and is brought to
you by the United Guild of the
existentially terrified if an instance
scp-3077-2 happens to wander its way
into the vicinity of any humans that
haven't succumbed to the process of
consuming
scp-3077-1 it will proceed to put on a
jaunty performance for its Newfound
audience this peculiar display involves
clumsy efforts at dance choreography and
the throaty singing of unsettling
Eternal Melodies that would make your
annoying cousins road trip songs sound
like they're in tune these awkward
performances continue until the audience
departs from the view of
scp-1377-2 instance or the instance
expires this confirms that the point of
the gesture is to entertain as without
an audience the
scp-3077-2 instance is not compelled to
make any noises of its own accord and in
general doesn't do anything other than
move around aimlessly in the event that
any number of
scp-3077-1 instances escapes from
containment and causes the creation of
scp-3077-2 members of the mobile task
force are instructed to never stray from
the line of sight of a currently
performing
scp-3077-2 instance and to approach it
steadily before restraining the instance
while causing minimal harm to the body
scp-3077-2 instances can be useful for
running further tests on the anomalous
properties of scp-3077 and there are
simple procedures that allow an instance
to be kept alive indefinitely in
containment any damage sustained doesn't
capture can severely hamper the
efficiency of these life-sustaining
procedures the worst case scenario is
that an
scp-3077-2 instance expires before being
securely contained as this will cause
the scp-3077-1 instance to emerge from
its host and resume its Relentless
attack on all nearby humans it is far
easier to Simply deal with
scp-3077-2 instances accordingly and
this is because
scp-3077-2 only ever attempts to
continue the performance and possesses
neither the intention nor the capacity
for retaliation if it is deemed
necessary for the effectiveness of a
recapture effort it can be permissible
for the model task force to allow
instances of scp-3077-1 outside of
containing to find purchase within
scp-3077-2 to increase the ease of
containment and lessen the risk of
foundation Personnel being affected the
performances of
scp-3077-2 instances are really
physically intensive enough to make
capture too difficult but it can be said
that the Whimsical antics of these
affected humans are anything but
predictable during some rare and special
performances and if the scp-3077-1
instance in control of
scp-3077-2 instance is feeling
especially daring it may try to show off
an array of woefully inadequate
acrobatic skills front flips that are
more like belly flops backflips that
could be mistaken for pret Falls and the
sort of type Road Pen trapezags that are
better left to the imagination in lieu
of Playa incidents the foundation
strongly advises that if for any reason
an instance of
scp-3077-2 must exist in containment it
must always be prevented from being at
an altitude of more than six feet from
the surface of the floor especially if
any humans it would perceive as an
audience are located directly beneath
where its performance would take place
regarding the creation of other
instances of
scp-3077-2 requests from any level of
foundation Personnel at site 81 or
elsewhere must be granted permission to
proceed by scp-3077's head researcher
because of the horrific implications of
what happens to the stellawair human
mind while the body is affected by
scp-3077-1 this process is only to be
approved for use on d-class Personnel
that's right and even then in the event
that all the regular all of the
paperwork goes through it is not
acceptable to create an instance of
scp-3077-2 merely for the purpose of
providing live entertainment to fellow
researchers after all not a single one
of us should be quick to forget the
grotesque and highly regrettable
spectacle that was Dr dietz's deplorable
d-class dancers every researcher
involved with that ethical nightmare was
reprimanded severely and the colorful
novelty costumes and jangling bells that
all former d-class Personnel were made
to wear after being reclassified to
scp-3077-2 have been permanently
confiscated let the cotton candy machine
and peanut dispenser located just
outside the containment unit of scp-3077
serve as a stand reminder that there's a
time and place for Monkey Shines and
and sometimes yes even now and then a
highly secure Foundation facility is
neither the right place nor the right
time in case you haven't picked up on it
there are very few practical
applications of scp-3077 due to the fact
that its status as a food dish is
negated by the consequences of
consumption the main reason for tests to
be administered on
scp-1377-2 instances is to discover if
there is a safe method of extracting an
scp-3077-1 instance from the body of its
host without causing the exploration of
the original human unfortunately due to
a persistent lack of success the
experiments have been discontinued
indefinitely but that just won't do how
else are we supposed to know if these
things actually taste as good as they
look I won't rest until everyone is able
to harmlessly ingest a sugar Golem of
their very own I might be old-fashioned
but to me the safe object class isn't
just a designation it's an invitation
again I ought to be completely okay
doing whatever I like around a saved
object because it's safe that word
should actually mean something ding ding
darn it and I don't mean that in the
sense that the SCP Foundation uses it
meaning an anomaly that doesn't present
an active threat to containment efforts
and more importantly there aren't that
many anomalies that are also delicious
candy and I want to eat this one sorry
sorry sorry I lost my cool a bit there I
just have a sweet tooth and my brain is
constantly drifting back to my nostalgic
childhood memories of playing Candyland
with my family that was before they all
decided that they wanted nothing to do
with me because I became so obsessed
with dressing up like a carnival marker
that I drove away everyone who's ever
cared about me other than that my job
here at the foundation explaining
confectionaries CPS is the only thing I
have left in my sad sad life some days I
feel less like Gloppy and more like a
real lord licorice in Hard Times Like
These a fellow could really use some
entertainment to cheer himself up wait
just a flea jumping moment what was that
what a big idea how do these Escape
instances of
scp-1377-2 get in here they're all
supposed to be in safe containment a few
floors down did somebody else from the
research team let them in here because
they knew I was in costume standing in
front of a pretend Fairground set that's
in pretty poor taste don't you think pun
very much intended I should probably
report it to the head researcher that
would be the ethical reasonable thing to
do then again look at them go those are
sure some hilarious dances I'm
definitely seeing a Snappy attempt at
doing the Charleston uh classic and is
that one doing the wormer is it just
kind of flopping on the floor I think
one of these instances knows about that
fortnite stuff how the kids are into
these days but I'm not sure if the human
element or the Golem that decides what
dances it knows either way this was
exactly what I needed to feel so much
better for once it feels like I'm
actually at a carnival instead of just
pretending to be at one now this is the
greatest performance I've ever seen in
all my years which you can be sure that
there have been a lot of now go check
out scp-261 pan-dimensional vending
machine and scp-5962 one night at
McDonald's for more anomalies that will
really wet your appetite